alexandria ocasio-cortez has been
pushing to defund israel's iron dome
defense system what is the iron dome
defense system well it is a system of
anti-rocket rockets when rockets are
launched from gaza or other places the
iron dome tracks those missiles down and
destroys them in the air it is a
defensive system to protect israel from
terror attacks
for that reason or for whatever reason i
don't know for whatever reason aoc
wanted to defund this one billion
dollars taken out of the budget bill so
that israel would not get funding to
build their defensive system
well
he went to a vote and unsurprisingly
420 people voted yes to fund the iron
dome that is bipartisanship right in
front of your eyes aoc began crying
i think this is important because it
shows you uh look i know a lot of people
are probably like oh tim's just ragging
on aoc
you know it really does show you that
this progressive
world or whatever it is this world view
is fake that auc has so much support
all over the country and all of this
money and she's so popular with all
these followers and that position held
by her followers is like defund the iron
dome and then basically everyone in
congress is like yeah
we're not gonna do that that's insane
and she starts crying over it she is
nowhere near
the average american she represents a
fringe minority and this is the perfect
example and her behavior is a perfect
example but there is really really big
news as well
gas shortages driver shortages becoming
gas shortages becoming natural gas
shortages my friends i hope you're
paying attention to this but we do have
a bunch of other news and updates we'll
get into we are being joined today by a
political activist somebody with
experience in biological research i
suppose malcolm flex
how's it going man you want to introduce
yourself oh don't mind if i do yes so uh
i actually go by malcolm flix and pretty
much i am what you would call a mishmash
of a bunch of different recurring tropes
and themes all rolled into one package
but one of the most salient themes that
a lot of people see on my social media
is that yes i do work in research and
biological of the sort which has pretty
much become in vogue you know given the
recent events that you know we'll
probably delve into
so know a lot about scientific method
about research all you know all that
good jazz that people are now saying
that we should trust blindly even though
it's antithetical to science but hey
yeah and general news have a good
conversation oh my god i love general
news good lord it's a break but yeah all
right
man thanks for coming we got ian's
hanging out actor musician social media
entrepreneur coming at you what's up
talent stack baby i love it good to see
you again brother hello everyone
here we are yeah and i'm gonna try to
keep the mood a little bit light because
malcolm loves to deliver black pills and
tim is not the cheeriest commentator
himself
before we get started recognize the end
is here and all this i'm kidding go to
teamcast.com become a member and you'll
get access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim castro podcast
however
we're actually about to launch the green
room show surprisingly uh soon because
this is when the guests show up and
there's a few minutes where they're
chilling they're at the bar in the green
room and we film these conversations
that are fairly random and i think it's
really fun so we're gonna those are
about 15 minute segments that will be up
exclusive for members and they'll exist
nowhere else just so that there is more
content we can produce for you and we
have the mysteries show we're waiting
for the music to be completed but we're
almost there so that should be about a
week or so perhaps hopefully fingers
crossed and you'll get an ad free
experience on all of our articles you'll
be supporting our fierce and independent
journalism but don't forget to like this
video subscribe to this channel share
this show take that url share wherever
you can help support the show by do by
word of mouth let's read the news
my friends this story from the daily
mail is a really good example of our
political dysfunction
aoc bursts into tears as iron dome's one
billion dollar funding is overwhelmingly
approved in-house
420 votes to nine rashida taleb is
accused of anti-semitism by fellow
democrat after she called israel a
violent apartheid system
nine
nine
that's what aoc represents she got 12
million followers on twitter
the that's what you need to understand
i'm going to start off and i'm going to
give you the hard facts and then we'll
talk about this stuff
aoc
does not represent her district
aoc represents fringe political
individuals across the country who
funnel money into her district which she
uses as a vehicle to sit in congress i'm
not saying that as to disparage her
character but to point out
her ideas probably don't fly in her own
district the things her district cares
about they probably don't know what
she's talking about but as nancy pelosi
said you could take a glass of water
with a d on it and it's going to win in
nancy or aoc's district that's what
nancy pulls in my or her district so
what happens is there's no real
republican competition there's no strong
primary aoc has too much money from
external sources the same is true for
other squad members their politics are
popular with fringe political groups but
a fringe political group is still
substantive when they can coalesce
online and funnel funding to politicians
like aoc
this manifests in aoc wanting to defund
israel's defensive system the iron dome
isn't bombing children it's protecting
israel from rocket attacks now by all
means criticize israel for all that
stuff i'm just saying iron dome that's
the job it does if you want to defund
israel like that why take away the iron
dome of all things that's what aoc tried
to do and as you can see
overwhelmingly like i mean beyond
overwhelmingly you get to see that auc
is shown what her politics really
represent nobody now i will say
there are a lot of conservatives
libertarians who are pointing out yet
but we shouldn't be funding the iron
dome why is the u.s giving a billion
dollars to israel for this and my
attitude is not you know i'm actually
partially in agreement with that i
actually think it's a great argument why
are we funding all this stuff even south
korea even in germany
that being said and we can discuss this
it represents that aoc is not in
alignment with where most people in this
country are
when they think about providing support
to our allies now people can certainly
say afghanistan is bad but israel's a
different story it's an allied united
states in a war-torn middle east that
provides stability and people support
that whether you agree with america's
foreign policy or not i think we we can
see here perhaps uh just good evidence
aside from like all the stories where
you see the media lying there's another
good example of how broken our political
system is
i don't know if you guys have any
thoughts
i i saw i think it was around occupy
wall street that something came out and
said the congress is like doesn't do
what the american people want they do
what their business associates want so i
think that this
massive
469 vote or whatever isn't necessarily
indicative that the american people want
it but that the politicians and their
business contracts want it
i
i somewhat agree with you
it is it is true that uh congress
typical like public opinion typically
does not move
congressional votes
but i gotta say man i do think the
majority of americans want to make sure
israel's not blown off the face of the
earth that's a big that's definitely a
big sticking point especially just even
when you look at moderate democrats i
mean they still have a healthy respect
for israel and you know there is still a
very big religious sect
section of our country and you know
israel holds this specific significance
you know whether or not you want to
debate against that or you want to
debate for that a lot of people israel's
still near and dear to them now i have
the question though for aoc
why do you want to see brown people get
blown up
like why
and it's just it's just a it's it's a
mindless talking point it is like
there's a legitimate talking point in
why are we providing funding you know to
these foreign like we should america
first is an argument right yeah we
should fix the pipes in our own cities
and the streets and the infrastructure
before we but then there's the art like
there is there's a legitimate argument
for the middle east is horribly
destabilized israel is a stable nation
they're an ally yes i get the argument
on the libertarian stuff about fun you
know funding and foreign policy stuff
okay i get that but we're not talking
about sending in troops we're not
talking about uh um
you know occupation we're talk we're not
talking about allowing them giving
selling weapons to the saudis we're
talking about the iron dome now if you
want to talk about israel being bad in
terms of how they what's going on with
gaza and the missile strikes
i'm fairly moderate on this one i do
think the real
the yeah i think the real argument comes
from the libertarian position not
necessarily just uh right wing just the
general
why are we focused on foreign excursions
the founding father said we shouldn't be
doing this kind of stuff and we are okay
fair point
most americans i think recognize that we
have international allies and that
israel is particularly vulnerable with
all of these different places in the
middle east i want to blow it up so we
provide them with military support and
out of 3.5 trillion a billion isn't as
much i got to say if you come to me and
you and you tell me that they want to do
12 million for pakistani gender studies
i'll be like that's insane if they say
we think there should be a missile
defense system for israel i'm like well
that i understand
now i'm a bit of a milk toast fence that
are on this one there's a foreign policy
argument versus a supporting or allies
argument the point is
aoc doesn't represent
like
does it doesn't represent america on
this in this regard i think she doesn't
represent america on most anything she
represents the french minority she
doesn't even go there i mean it's a odd
position to have number one that you
know it's a defensive system as you've
reiterated time and time again
why do you not want a nation to be able
to at least defend itself you okay you
can take the side that you want that you
side with hamas you think that a lot of
people
over there on that side have been
basically disenfranchised by the israeli
government and again
that's the conversation to be had but at
the same time
why do you want to basically disarm a
group and allow them to
be vulnerable to more combat more
injuries and proliferate the same
warfare that you complain about israel
you know just engaging in that's that's
a big issue so i'll i'll say this too
ian like i definitely agree with you on
the politicians are just supported by
their their big corporate donors and and
the political action committees what do
you think would happen if we defunded
the iron dome
oh there you'd probably see more attacks
on israel i would imagine i mean that's
a vague way of saying what might happen
and what will those more attacks result
in
with no defensive capabilities
you know obviously like death and
destruction of the infrastructure i
think it's a really kind of a structure
you have your infrastructure you mean
the people will start getting killed
death death and destruction of the
infrastructure it's it's kind of
it's kind of like a pie in the sky kind
of an ignorant thing to be like if we
stop funding it then it'll go away i
mean you see what cutting things out
cold turkey did over there in
afghanistan right again you can say what
you want yeah we shouldn't have been
over there but now that we're in it
again you cannot just leave it worse
than you you know worse than you came in
and that's the problem that felt like
was on purpose yeah again yeah i know
you've said it multiple times they're
punishing the anti-war people they're
like okay this is what happens when
america doesn't get involved people kill
themselves stuff happens a lot of really
great questions uh have arisen recently
which is really things are getting kind
of weird right so first people were
saying oh we should be in afghanistan
what about south korea or why are we
there and i'm like that's actually a
good point like i understand why we're
there because north korea they're still
a war and because they'd love to just
trample in
and they need support it's a good
question you know we went there because
of basically the cold war these proxy
wars and why are we in germany now that
donald trump asked and we all agreed why
are we in germany like let's get out so
afghanistan sausage
i get the idea of like protecting
afghanistan but all of a sudden people
start saying hey wait a minute if we
shouldn't be there should we be in these
other places and i think a lot of these
places the answer is no we shouldn't i
think the answer for afghanistan no we
shouldn't however i think the answer for
afghanistan was don't abandon bagram air
force base and provide logistics so that
the afghan army can maintain defense of
their cities and not let them fall so
quick and then lie about it after
they're sitting up here begging you
begging you for your air capabilities
just just a little bit just a smidge and
maybe a drone strike here you know hold
off the bad man for once joe biden for
once when you're being asked
midnight he did the drone strike but he
killed kids yeah i'm just like 10 people
missing his righteous right guys right
right we did it
we were asking you to to use your
military military capabilities against
the guys who are who are executing the
afghan soldiers
not the kids in the building in the
urban environment
so look
it's the democratic party man i'm sorry
they're a disaster in this regard you
know what else is crazy though is one of
the other things that's coming out of
this political space with the albert
tribalism is now we've even got i think
in florida they're questioning all
vaccine mandates
where they're basically like someone
said oh well you you're saying no
vaccine mandate for copen but what about
mumps and a guy went okay that's a good
point yeah let's get rid of the vaccine
and then it was like wait wait no don't
do that
so that's too fast we're opening
doors that should not be open and again
it's just the democrats are pushed there
you know they're treading on sacred
spaces that you know we have had
long-standing traditions for and now
they're over here trying to erode those
traditions and it's starting to cause a
lot of people to ask questions like okay
so why are we why are we doing it this
way if you're saying that this doesn't
work and the truth is they don't have an
internal layer of consistency behind a
reasoning it's partisan politics at its
finest and it's something that you get
when you don't have two healthy wings
you don't have a healthy democratic
party let me just say that yeah and the
republican party it's finally reforming
under this new populist base so what
ends up happening is that when one wing
is not healthy it's going to try to
choke the other you know
yeah and then what do you get you get
single party politics people like aoc
that sit up here and start pushing these
friends beliefs because again
they need you know they got to say
something well look at um you look at
some of these news stories like today
there's a story about steve bannon
and all these leftists are like steve
bannon admits to planning the
insurrection and then you actually watch
it and steve bannon's like on january
5th i was talking about trump to help
organize a rally and i'm like oh
and they took that and they turned it
into him saying like them saying he
planned the insurrection and then you
get lawrence tribe being like why isn't
the doj acting he's confessed it's
criminal code blah blah i'm like
they they don't know that the fbi said
there was no insurrection or they're
just idiots now imagine this a group of
people who don't know what's going on
who believe all this fake news and false
framing then going and voting on policy
for aoc she got a cold wake-up call like
hey guess what you're in a cult
people don't want this
look i don't like the ford intervention
and forever wars
israel's different i'm i'm it's that's a
rock and a hard place for me because i
understand the libertarian argument of
like let's not just give funding to
israel what's the point and then also
we're not asking for a military
occupation we're asking for an invasion
we're just saying like
these other countries want to wipe
history off the face of the earth okay
they can get a missile defense system
i'm not i'm not necessarily a big fan of
that idea but i'm also not in the
position where i'm going to be as strong
as i was in afghanistan or these other
countries and be like pull out all u.s
support for weapons and all that stuff
right
it's like what do you do again you're
already in it you gotta you gotta
actually go win it but can i just say
one thing
we need our top meme makers to get on it
make a meme of aoc crying with 420 in
the background
do it
this is for american history we need
this come on guys
dude i i like she's legit crying
no i'm not even playing like look at
this
so she's like
she's crying that's crazy to me man oh
god this israel things is so wild this
israel thing the country of israel then
there's like the jewish population and
it's like a a jewish state i think so
it's like a theocratic state which is
very unique in the world there's not a
lot of them anyway it's very very and
then you go back to the sykes pico
agreement and the balfour declaration
after world war one or during world war
one where they kind of set up israel
i got to stop you right there theater
theocratic countries like the majority
of countries yeah a religious government
they're hardline they do it they do
exist but they're not i guess not unique
but uncommon it's mostly no no most
states aren't religious states they are
they actually are you america's
particularly unique russia's not uh he's
not afraid i think you're wrong libya
or like um just the the having the
ability to question but knowing that
there is a power i can't quite remember
we're not a christian state uh what is
what i mean like it's a jewish state
it's like a jewish state well they are
the only jewish state but there are tons
of middle eastern countries that are
like muslim states like a lot a lot of
them i don't know about asian well like
um lots of asian countries as well there
are some muslim asian countries there's
india is like uh buddhist right yeah i
don't know
the indian subcontinent is very
religious but i know far east asia you
know they're a little bit interesting
because yeah they are very like
technocratic they're they're moving
beyond a lot of unified religion i mean
you just have too many religious
practices there anyways that you can't
have a unified state religion right
right and that's it's not a problem i
mean it what sometimes i think what
confuses is that judaism is a religion
but
judaism is also a bloodline so that's
unique in all religions there's no other
religion where you're like a christian
by blood it's always do you choose to
become
true but i don't think the belief
structure of the people in israel is the
issue here and i wonder if i wonder if
part of the strong reaction to what aoc
wanted was because of what happened when
we pulled out of afghanistan you know in
a way it kind of is because the jewish
population not maybe not needed but they
didn't have a place to live they were
like persecuted throughout time for
whatever reason and so they needed a
place to find
to live to settle and it was either
going to be in northeast africa and then
they decided to move it to where it is
today i got a i got an update check um
80 countries have a state religion out
of 195 countries in the world so i would
i would argue that's fairly yeah almost
almost almost half almost half so maybe
maybe uncommon is
a little unfair but it's not completely
what makes it unique is that it's a
culture and a religion that's very
unique judaism is incredibly unique um i
when you look at the way it was formed
basically the british and the french
betrayed the arabs to form it so the
arabs have had this stick about i want
that land you told us we could have that
you're treading on on thin ice yeah look
at the sykes pico agreement so the arabs
betrayed the ottomans in world war one
and that's how basically the allies won
the war the the french and the germans
or the the british and the french won
the war and the the french and the
british promised the arabs that area
nations right uh maybe yeah i'm not 100
sure and and then so when they they won
the war the arabs betrayed the ottomans
and our side won and then they they you
know they said sorry we're not going to
give you that land now and so the arabs
are like it's 100 years later and
they're still like it's you you said it
was ours
here's here's what i say to most people
right there's there's there's really
interesting challenges when you have
older generations making political
arguments off experiences the younger
generations don't have
i grew up in a world where there's the
israeli-palestinian conflict it's a it's
literally there's war going on and
everybody wants to make justifications
for why some one country should should
have control of this land or that
country or this land or this state
agreement two-state agreement one state
agreement and i'm like
yo i wasn't alive for most of this and
over time there's attrition in
the conflict was started by people who
are long since dead and we're now at a
point where
you can make any argument in the world
you want for land ownership
but throughout history its people and
land are conquered
and i'm not a fan of war and i'm not a
fan of of uh provocation and aggression
but at this point
i don't know
and so so right now it's just like yo
stop fighting
hey get a missile defense system so you
can stop the missiles it's kind of like
the monkey it's kind of like the monkey
in the ladder thing you know something
becomes tradition
originally the tradition had a pragmatic
purpose but then at some point
people just constantly repeat that
tradition over and over and over again
until the original meaning was lost even
if it doesn't exist but now the question
i have is
if you support israel
but you're also fairly you know
conservative does that mean that you
support a post-national authority making
such a big ruling such as this land
should be ceded to the israeli because
that's what the league of nations is and
we fought against post-national
authorities like again like um the eu
you know that whole deal trying to have
this whole one world order type of thing
that's what they tried to establish back
in the day
they're still they're doing they're
still i mean they still want to so do
you support that because that's the
that's basically the argument that i
hear a lot of times when they say that
you support
israel's right to be a country you say
that post national authority that's long
gone long dissolved
supersedes anybody else's claim to that
land you know we got this this is this
is a much too complicated subject you
know i would say i don't support
post-national authority but israel is a
country now it's there so we can't
pretend like we're not deciding whether
or not we're going to create it anymore
it's there it's like afghanistan we
shouldn't have just pretended like it
never happened and disappear we can't do
that with israel israel is a real place
we got to treat it like well they're in
their challenges with the west bank yeah
palestine supposedly is a real place you
know but i don't i don't i don't i don't
have enough knowledge yeah we you know
i'll get flack if i'm like hey the west
the bank and the illegal settlements
what's up with that and then i'll get
two completely distinct arguments to
completely distinct sense of facts and
i'm like this history is so deep seated
that you can't you you can actually look
up historical sources that will
contradict another historical source and
it becomes impossible exactly two too
many motivations uh we just have to let
it play out in hope
and you know depending on your religious
prediction pray that there's some kind
of peace there i would pray for
religious tolerance among the the arab
what is it the jude the judaist
population
the jewish population and then who the
arabs are muslim is muslim population
like
the united states is so wonderful with
our religious you know congruency that i
would love to see that there i
in israel
it's like i've been in tel aviv you walk
around everything's like it feels like
america almost i mean obviously people
are speaking hebrew and i couldn't speak
it like a hebrew so i was unable to like
shop
but i'm walking around and it was just
like people going to malls and you know
there was like food carts and stuff it
was just fairly urban and
like i i say secular in the sense that
people wore regular clothes like you'd
experience in any any major city i've
been to egypt
and
when when i was at the hilton at a
casino and egyptian citizens are it's
illegal for them to enter they've been
to morocco
like they have these laws it's very very
very different
so
you go to israel and a lot of people are
like it's a very secular place in the
middle of a lot of religious theocracy i
feel like that's almost the prototype
and i know there was a lot of financial
interest when it came to afghanistan but
i feel like that was kind of the
prototype for what we were trying to set
up in afghanistan you know minus again
halliburton and all the military
contractors and again setting up that
whole counter-turkey pipeline deal you
know having staging area over that way
well how about we move on to different
subjects speaking of the cutter turkey
pipeline see that's a good one a lot of
people don't know a lot about the
pipeline uh the cutter turkey pipeline
is basically the basis for what's the us
involvement in syria i love bringing it
up because people know this the us has
been preparing to invade syria going
back well before the syrian civil war
they wanted to have qatar build a
pipeline up through syria through turkey
into europe to offset russian gas
monopolies and syria said we will not
betray our ally russia so then the u.s
is like we're going to destabilize syria
and then they won't be allies anymore
and surprise surprises yeah we needed
access to europe and syria was in the
way and then russia and syria said we're
gonna have iran tap the same gas well
and then send the the pipeline through
iraq and it was just like
wow
basically the u.s had a plan and they
were like we're gonna undercut you and
this is like war
but anyway speaking of gas
we're in trouble baby we got this story
from dw.com
bp limits uk petrol deliveries as driver
shortage bytes the old company is set to
restrict deliveries of petrol and diesel
to some gas stations in the face of a
driver shortage happening in the uk like
we saw here in the us a lack of drivers
a lack of stations and then and then
what we saw in the u.s was that the
federal government comes out and they're
like there is no gas shortage and then
you're like then why are all my gas
stations empty oh because your gas
stations are empty but we have gas
nationally and it's like yo that's a gas
shortage like for me and my family and
where i live and then we get this
from the economist
natural gas shortages threaten
government's green goals
the us dollar is backed by energy
by oil by fossil fuels
people need to understand that the
comfort of their lives here in the
united states is based on the fact that
we print these dollars we borrow this
money we just manifest it and we can buy
oil with it but with these energy
shortages you want to talk about crises
a food shortage is bad what you're going
to eat
but if we have the energy to produce it
could be an economic bump but if we
don't have the energy if we don't have
the drivers to transport it yo the long
fall is coming soon man
addicted to electricity
i remember i said built upon it are we
are we addicted to the chair like that
we're sitting sitting on chairs addicted
to oxygen no but people say we're
addicted to fossil fuels and i'm like no
fossil fuels are the support beams which
support our civilization that we've
built upon when we live when we're in a
skyscraper where like it's unfortunate
we're addicted to these central steel
columns
no that's just what we built to maintain
the structure and structure i think
electricity is a natural evolution of
our species
it is um to a certain extent i mean
again electricity powers a lot of
processes you need electricity just as a
mere means of converting you know energy
in
let me ask you a question yeah
how do we make electricity in the ice
you have to use you do have to use gas
you've got to power certain mechanical
apparatuses and they always run on the
chemical energy from gas
so uh what do we do with the gas i'm not
trying to put you on the spot okay it's
it's it's grilling you uh typically
drill it you uh transport it via
pipelines it's got little substations
weight stations you can get it certainly
but then what do we do with the gas to
get electricity
you don't have to know most people don't
right go ahead and tell me so we
uh in in gas factories
we will burn the gas to heat water which
creates pressure and spins a turbine a
large magnet and a rotating magnetic
current creates an electric
rotating rotating magnetic field will
create will generate an electrical
current
so uh but natural gas isn't the only way
it's not the most prominent i think uh
coal
is actually still the most uh
the the plurality of how we produce
energy uh do you know how we turn coal
into electricity
go into the process all right so we
heated it we set it on fire and that
energy out of the coal heats water which
creates pressure and the steam pressure
exiting you know the system will spin at
turbine large magnetics rotating will
create an electrical current
so do you know how solar farms uh
generate electricity or actually this is
nuclear power you know nuclear power yes
now nuclear power is one of the that's
actually one of the easier ones where
you actually split say a
subatomic particle again it actually
releases it releases the alpha waves the
beta waves but the gamma waves are high
energy and then you can actually contain
that and you know how do we turn that
nuclear reaction into electricity
the rods are sitting in water which
boils
steam pressure then spins a turbine a
large magnet all right now solar farms
this is my fault i love this
now there's two kinds to be fair but
early solar farms were giant arrays of
mirrors
focusing sunlight on large vats of i
believe salt water which pressurized to
spin a turbine yo the way we make
electricity in this country is figuring
out ways to boil water i'm sensing it i
was just about to say i'm sensing the
theme huh
salt molten salt
thorium salt reactors yep they'll boil
salt and it'll stay hot for days so you
get heat all night conductive and you
can boil the water with it we do now
have photovoltaic solar fields which
it actually the photon
hits an electron causing it to move
generating a current and so once we get
to a certain level of
of efficiency but the simplest way to
put it is we generate like electricity
by spinning turbines getting a large
magnet to spin creates a current so we
have tidal energy this is really really
cool when the tide comes in it the
pressure against the generators spins
turbines you got geothermal the natural
gas from the vents spins a turbine you
got wind literally just wind spinning a
turbine so we're just trying to make
things spin that's how we do it
basically
that's the mechanical process right
there exactly so i'm not trying to put
you on the spot it's just most people
most people don't know because they
don't look into it and you ask someone
like how does solar energy work and
they're gonna assume photo photovoltaic
which is true that's a fair you ask them
about nuclear and they'll tell you about
a nuclear process you say coal will say
we we burn the quality but what does
that process do
so i'll tell you where we're at
people don't understand what life was
like before all this energy this
extinction rebellion group greta tunberg
you want to go back to 1850 i mean we
have we still had fuels back then go
back to when our number one source of
fuel was wood
and then you're chopping down trees
you're chopping them up you're burning
them for heat and for smelting and stuff
and you will see a life you do not want
to live
now i'm not saying it's not a life worth
living i think working in the fields
with your bare hands and having a cow or
a bowl pull the the you know the thing
till the fields the till or whatever
it's called
today
we have such an abundance of all this
energy gigantic robots do all the
farming and we sit back in our lounge
chairs eating our ho ho's and our papa
john's watching the football game that
is coming to an end more calories and
more calories in and calories out but
that changes and yeah we built too much
of a society around you know it's like
when you scale up eventually you have to
say create new processes that can help
you mass produce energy mass reduce
everything and you know again keep going
but what happens if that energy source
gets cut off you're left with a bunch of
useless machinery that's right you can't
even run and here's and here's the scary
thing
all right
we built an infrastructure on on this
chemical process notably like diesel and
gasoline
if we lose that for whatever reason
these machines we don't we don't we have
what do we do like if you have a worker
in the field that he's got a shovel
and then
that worker moves or passes you find a
new worker
the tool can still be instantly applied
to another person but if we lose our
principle source of energy fossil fuels
we have an entire technological
infrastructure that doesn't adapt to any
kind of other energy now we can start to
adapt it like let's say we start using
hydrogen cells and we power things we do
electric vehicles electric farming
equipment which i'm sure they do a lot
of
probably because i think
well i'll say this tesla is not
profitable is my understanding the tesla
cars
only profitable because they were tax
subsidies now they're now that those
have expired it's no longer
profitable to make these vehicles unless
they jack the price up
so
if tomorrow you know we're looking at
these gas shortages across the u.s and
in the uk if tomorrow all of a sudden
there's no gas
people can't drive buses can't run
machinery can't work everything we do is
stopped and then we go back
what 70 years and have to restart our
infrastructure on other energy systems
or whatever
you can't do it and then even the
transition you're going to have to
double your production of whatever you
know you're basically going ahead and
replacing it with because you have to
have enough to keep production of let's
say the batteries that you're going to
power electric vehicles you've got to
literally have enough batteries to power
what you're using to replace i know this
sounds uh super you know it sounds super
circular but to what you're using to
actually replace the means of producing
the batteries you gotta eventually
transition those off so yeah and how do
you get the lithium you lose it yeah
so people don't get man you lose energy
we're going to we're going to build a
bunch of electric vehicles and it's like
oh yeah what machines do you use to get
the lithium out of the ground and
they're like well we use gas powered and
diesel powered
it'd be cool to start fusing hydrogen
helium and making lithium maybe that
does that work well it's the next it's
element three so i would imagine yeah i
don't know if they do it at scale
probably not i would imagine fusion
creation i know they do um they can make
diamonds
by uh put seeding carbon and then having
a neon gas or something works yeah yeah
i think science can save us i think uh
that that's why i like the original idea
of the green new deal i'm like that
sounds cool you know we we allocate
taxes towards uh building new energy
infrastructure could help make america
energy independent energy independence
means a wealthy and strong america and
then i'm like i like the sound of this
and then aoc comes out and says the
green new deal and i'm like okay and
then she goes is free college for people
who aren't white and healthcare and i'm
like wait what
that's paul johnson in that show yeah
right good idea
poor execution phys.org researchers
simulate compact fusion power plant
concept i mean we are there dude fusion
fusion fusion where is the media talking
about fusion why do they want to sell
this oil so much too
i mean return on energy investment is
substantially higher than what we can
predict at a fusion
so and it's portable you know oil is
you take a look at uh what's called
energy return on energy invested and oil
is the best i think actually i think
nuclear is the best
but the left hates
nuclear power so we can't get it i know
generally the problem is that the word
nuclear because fission historically was
pretty dirty but fusion's a completely
different process they shouldn't call
them this both nuclear yeah but we're
not there with fusion yet
will we ever be we've always been like
five years away since like the 80s
because like how do you think from
pre-production to actual production you
know for the big time if you still have
these challenges that's the question
that you actually have to ask for fusion
like what challenges so typically with
fusion i think that to reliably
it's kind of like what tim said you know
when you actually deal with like energy
costs like it's
an extremely expensive process i think i
remember if i'm not from
if i'm not mistaken with fusion where
they actually use magnesium they
actually force the molecules together
and again
or they actually force the subatomic
particles together and it releases the
energy but i think that it just takes so
much energy to actually do that that
again you're going to lose out
heavy water which is called deuterium
oxide it's it's uh
h2o but the hydrogen has an extra
neutron so it's heavier and they put it
inside of a palladium lattice and then
they
they
they do something i think they electrify
the palladium and it causes the whereas
hydrogen is so light it will fly away
from itself when they aim it but because
the heavy water is heavier they can ram
it into itself and create helium that's
one way they can do tabletop fusion
and then what happens i guess is the
system causes some kind of like
vibration that they have to figure out
how to capture it
so right now what's happening is they've
reached ignition
but that's like
you ever try and start a fire with a
torch
and you're holding the torch on the wood
and the wood stops on fire and you take
the torch off the fire goes away
you need to get the energy levels to
enough where it's self sustaining and
we're not there yet so fusion sounds
fantastic but nuclear energy is probably
our path out of this the only problem is
you've got an activist left that won't
let us do it
vision yeah
there's three mile island and what else
the russian nuclear substantially
substantially more people have died from
coal mining than from nuclear energy and
i get it fukushima is really really bad
and that devastating consequences we
probably won't even know about for a
long time but that just means we need
better safety standards it means we
better better adaptation for nuclear
technology people seem really afraid of
of the unknown and when it comes to
nuclear you can't see the radiation
whereas coal you can kind of like see
the smoke so you know what it is but
with like covid for instance you can't
see it yeah with with radiation you
can't see it so there's this like fear
about the things you can't see
is it in me or is it not i don't know so
that's even worse well i mean we've uh
you know we predicated a whole society
on surviving based on calculating the
unknown to the best of our ability and
so again when you kind of step outside
of that and you leave it to chance you
know especially with something like
energy and you know nuclear energy to
begin with you know if you fail to
safely dispose of those rods when you're
doing fission or you know you don't cool
it properly again
you know catastrophic circumstances do
you really want to leave that the human
error to one you know miscalculation or
just
uh let's say a worker that's just very
ambivalent about his job doesn't
go through protocol properly i heard a
crazy story once where like some diver
got sucked into a nuclear cooling system
intake tube
and he was swimming in the nuclear pool
totally fine
because radiation can't go through water
ah yeah so he was like at the top and
they saved him and he was like i had
this theory about recovering nuclear
waste the corium is the core is called
corium it melts when there's a meltdown
it's it's producing so much heat the
heat's not getting out of the core so it
keeps getting hotter and hotter hotter
and then it just melts and it goes
through the thing that's holding it down
into the ground through the ground but
what i was thinking is if we put some
sort of superconductive metal in it
then it would allow it to release its
heat so like gold if you poured gold
into aquarium
then i would imagine that over time it
would start to release its heat and then
you'd have this hardened corium gold
thing and then you could maybe retrieve
the gold that maybe maybe there's some
infrastructure utility companies sitting
there going
ian is just salt no problem
you've done your research on it yeah
there's i was looking at the
temperatures of gold gold's a good one
there are other conductive uh platinum
metals that might work as well and you
got to get in there so you need like
drones and most of the drones they've
powered down when they get so close to
that heat yeah but then what do you do
with all the uh constantly destabilizing
isotopes and all of that they're just
kind of you know they're they continue
to vision they've been recycling uh this
stuff i think like 99 recycled really
yeah so like the technology that most
people are complaining about comes in
nuclear is from the 70s and we've
greatly improved i mean i think thorium
salt reactors have been prominent for
some time people have been discussing
the possibility it's already melted like
you're you're mentioning like melted
salts or whatever so
i mean
it seems like we have a path towards
better energy generation to avoid fossil
the problem of carbon emissions but this
is the strangest thing you get these
people like greta tunberg yelling how
dare you demanding that we cut all
fossil fuels and we're like i think
nuclear energy would work and they're
like nah you can't have that either it's
like do you want me to live in the woods
i'll chop down trees that's exactly
that's what they want that's exactly it
they want us to go carbon negative and i
mean the the deal is again there's no
way to stop this whole climate change
bugaboo that you that you want to let
you go carbon negative which basically
means that you have to start destroying
a lot of manufacturing because you can
go carbon what do you think they're
doing
it's unfortunate because you can
withdraw
you can take the carbon out of the
atmosphere and deposit carbon dioxide
onto other metals like palladium and
then create graphene oxide so you can
actually pull the carbon dioxide out of
the air we'll end up competing with
trees if because i think we're going to
pull the carbon out of there yeah we'll
start mining the carbon out of the air
and then the trees are going to be like
hey balance it out we can't build an
entire infrastructure around taking the
carbon dioxide away
right that's better than destroying
industry because we're gonna have to
learn how to make
synthesize oil in other ways like super
pressurized dirt we've done that we've
grown algae and then made petroleum from
algae burn it off recollect it i was
listening to this podcast
called like was it called like stuff you
should know no what is it yeah i think
it's stuff you should know maybe not
maybe i don't want it's not really a big
one yeah and they were like it's like
three guys or something
and this is a couple years ago they were
like
what are we gonna do when there's no
more you know fossil fuels are dead
dinosaurs what are we doing there's no
more and the one guy goes there's not
going to be any more dinosaurs dude and
i'm like wow
people listen to this stuff
did you fossil fuels are not dead
dinosaurs please please did you guys
hear about these nuclear batteries
they're taking uh spent nuclear waste
and putting it inside of carbon glass
like carbon diamond glass and it's
producing like basically like ten
thousand years of electricity out of it
so these particles out yeah
oh yeah that's awesome see if i can pull
this up this came out batteries that
never die nuclear batteries it's all
over if you look up nuclear batteries
you'll see tons of stuff on it
ten thousand years so not never in the
grand scheme they'll be like they only
last ten thousand years
we live for nine hundred thousand so
it's not good enough
a new approach to carbon free tech and
it recovers nuclear waste that's one of
the cool things about it
sounds awesome now the question i have
to ask though is again is the carbon
really as detrimental as they keep
saying because i think they said back in
what was it 2012 that we were past the
anthropogenic tipping point of carbon to
where there's no way we can recover
everything's set in motion and this is a
third so i have to ask my i have to
pause and just ask and again i'm not an
energy expert but you know by any means
but
haven't we already hit the point to
where you know if something was going to
happen based on all the carbon buildup
in the atmosphere
like aren't we there and hasn't
everything still been okay and you know
obama still buying the beachfront
property and all of that you know like
there's a certain level of trust that's
been eroded in what these people are
saying to where should we really be
devoting a lot of energy
towards you know all these emission
standards when we cut our manufacturing
we cut our industry and then china is
basically over there producing all the
dirty dirty energy they want and you can
see the clear financial impetus for it
so
like is it really that important i got
this website energy live news
never heard of it but they say eternally
charge smart watches to become real with
nuclear waste powered battery could last
up to 28 000 years
they say the battery for the smart watch
will last eternally for its entire
lifetime we should have this smart watch
released within 18 months
cool then you can put those in your car
you'll be able to put those
maybe you could be able to stitch them
into your clothing why couldn't you have
a smartphone that just never died
exactly that to me that's that's crazy
if that's true yeah then they wouldn't
make all the money uh selling you the
power blocks separately since they don't
put them in the boxes anymore so are
they gonna be able to contain the
radiation so you don't die yeah i think
so these things are really cool these
nuclear batteries is a big deal dude i
got i got i mean look i got to make this
call get these dang tweets off i can't
be concerned about those minutiae you
know my new details guys come on way
more important so couldn't you just hook
up like one of those batteries to the
outside of your house because i know
they were talking about tesla batteries
and i don't know if there's like a
similar application theoretically yes
you could i don't know you have a really
really big version a smartwatch is tiny
right the nice thing is it encourages
nuclear power because you're going to
create more nuclear waste you can
convert it to batteries after you're
done with the power plants yeah is this
kind of like what tim said you know with
the uh with the example of again the use
of turbines
all of our energy production methods
just scale off of one simple theme that
once we unlock it again we can continue
to scale it up and innovate and turn
into something new but man we're asking
too many questions the epa is going to
start knocking around
epa
as far as i know these aren't steam they
they i think it's alpha i think they
release alpha particles that vibrate you
can look them up on uh on a wikipedia i
know they give you a nice kind of a
visual overlay of what happens inside
the battery how it like releases these
particles outside through the carbon
glass catches the energy i'm not sure if
it's using piezoelectricity or not
sounds like an opportunity that we're
not going to get to because the left
doesn't want nuclear power so come
expert come join us sound progression
yeah what is a big business they're like
no let's just stick with what we got
ride it out but like we're cool on that
you know we could have infinite energy
but you know i i think we're okay i'll
tell you it feels like
what the left does they accuse the right
of all the time
they project so the left has big
business interests driving a lot of
their agenda and then they accuse the
working-class rural guy who's like i'm
gonna vote for the guy who's gonna end
the opioid crisis and they say you're
you're working for a big pharma it's
like i literally don't want people
buying this medication while you're
promoting massive
no liability contracts bingo bingo and i
mean again you got to think about it if
you were an evil well not even evil if
you just wanted profit at all costs and
you wanted everybody thrown off your
trail and you have control of all of the
mass media apparatus wouldn't you just
project wouldn't you just you know
publish falsities and say your enemies
are doing that given how you know humans
are devolving to the point where we're
exhibiting a lot of tribal behavior a
lot of our primitive
you know just urges we're kind of
getting into and that whole tribal
behavior of this other guy's wrong we're
right we're going to fight you tooth and
nail you know there's no con there's no
discussion in the middle that's that's
what they're thinking oh yeah like like
i mentioned on the russell brand
interview i did he put up a segment
about civil war and the comments were
right-wing people saying tim pool's a
leftist and left-wing people saying tim
paul's right wing success now mike isn't
it isn't it amazing there's there's no
middle you're either with us or against
us exactly and that's where we're going
i will say though
you take a look at independent voters i
can i you know i can have a conversation
with i'll throw it back to when i went
to sweden you know when paul joseph
watson was like i challenged a
journalist to go to sweden or whatever
and i was like i'll do it and he was
like i was kind of just taking the piss
and i was like i'm gonna do it anyway
and he's like all right i'll donate to
your thing and then his whole attitude
was very much like crime is really
really bad and i said well it's not that
bad um it is worse it's worse than it's
been but it's way worse than america the
thing is it's relative the people in
sweden they saw one murder of the prior
year now it's 13. that to them that's
that's massive that's a 1300 increase so
they're freaking out but it's not like
there's a war zone going on and the
response from paul on enforce is like oh
interesting yeah i hadn't considered
that thank you tim and i'm like
what am i supposed to do and the guys at
infowars are the ones being like oh well
how about that and if the people on the
left being like you're a liar and you're
crazy and i won't talk to you so it
makes it impossible i mean look i'll
tell you this
we've we've invited a ton of lefties
come on the show we say it all the time
they won't do it
they just don't do crossovers
maybe with some libertarians but i guess
you know what i think it is i think it's
um we fact check in real time
we have newsguard certified sources
which has a bias but we use that
specifically to be like hey we're using
a biosource on purpose microsoft for
instance and uh if any one of these
people comes and sits down
they're gonna get roasted yeah talking
points don't work again and
unfortunately the left is
you know their whole deal is closing
ranks they hand down their ideas like
doctrine whereas i think the right is
still kind of open source to it to a
degree because
the right goes by principles more so
than doctrines that's a good point
whatever the the there's two factions
and it's the centralized and the
decentralized that's that's really
basically what it is i mean that's how
the populist took over and that's why
you know the democrats you know they're
beating back the leftists with six yes
they capitulate every now and again
because it's just trendy and you've got
these kids that don't know any better
and they want to get them on board but
at the same time you know
the right one their revolt and took over
the republican party largely even if
it's just for show even if a lot of
politicians you know you just you get a
lot of these old these old guard
republicans that are now adopting the
whole populist message but even if it's
just sure trick primary them get them
out yeah yeah you want you want me to
vote republican
okay primary all these guys yes yeah all
of them
get them out and i'm pretty sure
everyone on the on the trial all the
trump supporters agree yes ryno's out i
do think it's fair to i think it's
unfair to call them rhinos though
republican in name only because i'm like
the truth be told the republican the
republican party and the majority are do
nothings yeah you know it's like the one
or two guys like rand paul maybe who's
gonna do something different so he's the
he's the one who's only republican in
name he's more libertarian and
principled at the beginning of the show
i was thinking i feel like american
politics has is is different now like
it's still the same suit american
politics but whoever's wearing it is
like because we're in the age of social
media and popularity contests now i
don't think that term that these endless
terms work anymore it's too it's too
easy to get super popular and then have
like totalitarian control basically so
we've really got to kind of
you know reboot or re-evaluate or
transition there's probably better words
i get what you're saying and i mean it's
happening to an extent the democrats
they run their party in a very 90 to
2000 era kind of way that's why they
focus on big media corporation and all
that whereas the right has already
evolved so the left is still the left
and i when i say left i don't mean the
true left i mean this neoliberal
establishment they are still operating
in the clintonian era where you know you
go up you get a celebrity to say some
good things about you and then you know
you dance around for the camera and then
you go back to your dark room but
remember when hillary clinton was
campaigning and she put on a southern
drawl when she was in like alabama or
wherever she was like yo we have the
internet they're back in the day
back in the day the politician could go
to chicago and be like i'm just like you
guys i got a garage door opener just
like you and they could go to new york
and be like yo you vote for me and both
of these guys are getting out and i'm
gonna wipe these guys out and
it worked people be like hey sounds like
me now when you do that they're like why
are you talking different aoc
actually did it remember when she like
she put on like a spanish
she put on a spanish accent yeah and
then people were like yo you don't sound
like that
and she was like i wasn't putting on an
accent that's just because i'm bilingual
and it's like dude
it it worked when we were only
newspapers it would be like hillary
clinton came and said these words but if
you actually heard it she tries to
imitate the people there she did that in
her campaign it doesn't work these are
different times you can't do that stuff
but they still think it's 20 years ago
why well nancy pelosi is what she 80
something years old how old is she she
won i think dianne feinstein's 90 isn't
she yeah at some point you know these
politicians they reach their shelf life
and you know i think the gop a lot of a
lot of the old guard politicians gop are
really about to probably bow out just
because they they see with the writing
on the wall and that it is good but the
issue is the right has a very big talent
scouting program think about this or i
mean a talent scouting
it or an issue with their talent
scouting program where
a lot of the people that you see come up
on the right you know they don't get a
lot of these people that are out on the
forefront on twitter making memes
spreading this information a lot of
these non-blue check but big name
influencers they don't scout those
people they get the interns the people
that work for somebody that they know to
come up the yes men
and that's who they put in and these are
anti-charismatic people they don't quite
understand or relate
and it's like getting somebody like
marjorie taylor green you can say what
you want about her cue stuff and all of
that but
she's different you know what i can't
stand republicans they'll wear suits no
i get it democrats in congress are
wearing suits but like conservatives
like mainstream conservatives show up to
events wearing suits 19 year old kids
wearing suits i'm like you are not
relatable to a regular working class
nobody wants that guy and it's like you
have all this talent right here
but you keep on picking the same old
same old and then you're wondering why
you're getting stomped out by these
people that are using twitch streams and
they're sitting up here they're they're
reaching out to the kids and they're
inspiring youth to become leftists you
know i think a lot of people
conservative pop that are really
successful people that happen to be sort
of going to business they don't go into
politics that's that's a big thing too
and you know that's that's honestly the
cycle that politics should follow is
that you should become
very proficient in something else in
life and then once you've done that once
you've accomplished all that you want
then go into politics that sounds pretty
similar to what trump did trump had
already made his money he had already
become a business magnate he had you
couldn't bribe him because he already
had everything so what do you want he
wanted the accolades of going into
politics and now when you have that
motivation
you're not out here trying to sell out
the highest bidder you're not out here
trying to wear a bunch of corporate
brands you're just trying to get your
legacy you know you're just trying to
get your legacy through and that's why i
didn't understand why they did not like
this guy like it's an insurance policy
trump gets in if he does bad his brands
suffer people remember trump as oh you
remember that guy that got in and he
just ruined everything kind of like what
we said about joe biden
like trump would not he wouldn't allow
that to happen so that's why i just
didn't get that but that's the cycle
that politics is supposed to follow but
you missed trump yet
i sure could go for some mean twits
right now all right
i would take 20 mean tweets yeah
prices yeah you know he's looking good
man yeah he looked at the fast food yeah
something like that i remember 2019 man
best economy people were cheering jim
cramer was like best members of our
lives covet happened i can't blame trump
for covered i know you know but i can't
you know he was going along with it he
should have fired five she's a lot of
things he could have done better but not
you know it's a natural disaster of
sorts
but under under his his administration
in the first few years i mean things
were skyrocketing yeah the economy was
through the roof booming business was a
booming now where are we i mean trump
didn't start any wars he was trying to
get our troops out of the middle east he
made some absolute foreign policy
mistakes often often with drone strikes
military strikes uh missile strikes
commando raids et cetera
but the past few past the last couple of
years he was like he's pretty good i'm
like all right you know
donald trump's got a potty mouth but
this ain't bad and then when joe biden
comes along i'm like i'll take the potty
mouth plus trump's second term agenda
was legit like school choice on there
yeah now we're now we're nine uh eight
months in
and it's like democrats voted for this
we got the border crisis
we got the afghanistan withdrawal
problem
we've got an economic crisis we've got
the eviction crisis we've got job
shortages fuel shortages food shortages
holy
joe biden screwed off i won't blame him
the economy was was on its way down even
though they gave it that one last ride
before they started printing the other
like we were already 18 trillion in
deficit but the ground but i mean at
that point you know the rhetoric around
lockdowns definitely accelerated it made
it worse and you know again there was
nobody to take the desantis approach and
just say hey guys let's just let's stop
this follow me trust me let's not lock
down because that's going to kill us
where we're at and
and there's a difference between the
debt and the economy the debt's a
problem it means you know we're going to
see inflation the government is
overspending it's over exerting itself
but when
you have debt the train is still moving
it's causing problems and it's bad but
when you just stop everything that was
the democrats now again donald trump
should have fired fouchy donald trump
was all about 15 days to slow the spread
but it was mostly democrat governors who
went hardcore trump does deserve some of
the blame for the cover response
absolutely he could have fired fouch he
could have said not a lot of this stuff
thought he was doing something good he
was like i'm going to race a vaccine out
as fast as possible everyone yay well
that was that was part of the issue
though that we took a vaccine-centered
approach again trump's original idea
with the red and green zones or however
they did it again just testing rapid
testing that was a much better approach
rapidly test the individuals you know
make sure number one the fact that we're
still using pcr is just you know it's in
the front because pcr doesn't detect
whether or not you're carrying a viral
load that you can actually transmit a
rapid test would be very much suited
towards that because that basically
gauges your load whether or not you can
actually give somebody covet or you
can't and then you quarantine the people
basically tell them hey go ahead and do
this stay away from these people and you
keep everything moving the fact is we
took a vaccine-centric repo approach
where we wanted to lock everything down
until we got vaccines well we got him
well hold on
we wanted to lock everything down for 15
days to slow the spread so hospitals
didn't overload within 15 days it turned
into just a couple more weeks then it
turned then it became just until we've
stopped coving
then it's like we'll get the vaccines
don't worry once we have the vaccines
then we're back to normal then we get
the vaccines and they're like okay well
you still got to wear your mask if you
get the vaccine then they're at the
point where they're like look we need
everyone to do weekly tests and if you
don't want to do a weekly test get the
vaccine now we're at the point where
they're like even if you've gotten the
vaccine you need a weekly test that's at
university of arizona are they still
doing pcr tests yes and so this is like
your expertise you're saying these pcr
tests are not accurate not as accurate
well it's not that they're not as
accurate they they get trace artifacts
and they basically do a polymer
chain reaction where they actually
recreate the covet particle using using
the other strand to the base pairing on
that rna so they can tell if you've had
coveted or if you your body's reacting
you got the antibodies but they don't
know if you're actually able to transmit
or not so they can't tell viral loads so
you could be asymptomatic with a very
limited load and they they can't see
that so they need different tests yeah
and i think it's really obvious they
went to this direction of even if you're
vaccinated you gotta get tested because
i said this couple weeks ago
how does it make sense that you're gonna
be like
you can't come to the movies unless
you're vaccinated or get weakly tested
and i'm like breakthrough cases exist
and people who have breakthrough cases
can transmit to the same degree as
someone with like who's not vaccinated
once you get once once you get covid
your chance of transmission is like
equal regardless of vaccination status
but those who are vaccinated are much
less likely to get that's what they're
saying but if that's still the case they
can transmit then doesn't everyone need
to test
but they were like no and i was like
okay now here we are university of
arizona is the first to be like yeah
everybody get your test so do you know
so now that this delta variant is out
are they still vaccinating for the
original variant even though there's a
new variant that's traveling so when
people are getting sick with covid are
they actually put in quotes are they
getting sick with a variant that the
vaccine is not prepared for there's all
sorts of different variants of you know
covid and the difference is that you can
have a variant of covet that literally
does absolutely nothing like if you go
ahead and you look at the sequencing
data on giza you'll see
so many different like on gz where they
share the actual data from the pcr tests
and from like people that they actually
confirm positives they can tell you what
prevalence that specific strain is
they've got a bunch of them and it's a
bunch of different areas just sharing
that data
so
you have variants that do absolutely not
you know nothing over the actual version
that's natural because the rna virus
you're going to get you know single
nucleotide polymorphisms where
again a coach you know one of the base
pairing skips or one of the base
pairings omits and it's not the right
one and so
the question is
what does the delta variant do do we
even know because a lot of people say
that it's more transmissible but you got
to think the delta variants started
coming around right as everybody started
getting coveted apathy you know
lockdowns were being released in a lot
of places they're brushing in it's like
how do you gauge transmissibility
if you're not infecting somebody
recovered telling them to go walk the
same distance around the same amount of
people
not touch anybody but get within this
distance you can't control
to see how transmissible a specific
strain is so do we know that it has any
and this is the hot button demonstrated
gain of function
over normal you know over the normal
star cov2 string
like that's the question that you have
to actually ask nobody like when someone
walks in if if something were to happen
we're like
this person got covered from that person
they i've never i i've been following
this for a while and i don't know they
don't say what strain they caught so i
keep thinking it's the original but
it might not be right well so so here's
what i think happened and i you know
consult your doctor cause i'm not an
expert on this but i was reading about
it and basically when we had the alpha
strain
it was like the original strain it was
it was it was brutal
it was more deadly less infectious but
what happens is natural selection occurs
right so the virus that caused the
viruses that cause outside of cover just
in general virus and you can probably
correct me if i'm wrong on this one but
viruses that cause more damage are less
likely to spread because the person
notices it and then takes action so
viruses that are less deadly and less
you know causing of symptoms are more
likely to transmit
naturally selecting for a highly
transmissible but less deadly variant
yeah so what happens is here's what i
think this is my opinion
the alpha variant i think was
nightmarish like the data we were
getting the videos we were seeing it was
horrifying we saw videos of people
collapsing in the street in china people
are now saying they're fake no i don't
think that's what what's happening i
think what happened was the initial
strain was people are saying it was like
a pressure on their chest and so you've
got people in china who are like
pressured to go out work and and you
know they have there's like a more honor
culture so it's like put a mask on and
get out there and then someone would be
struggling to breathe and what happens
when you can't breathe you pass out yeah
they're bad air there too anyway right
so you got bad air you've got pressure
on the chest and this weird like
pneumonia was going around so we see
this data and the initial
the initial data was like we could see
millions die from this in the u.s like
the new york times had a slider bar
models
but what happens is there's a natural
natural selection that occurs the most
severe strains or eliminating themselves
by killing people the less severe
variants were more likely to transmit
because the people were less likely to
be hospitalized so then we went alpha we
had beta you know now we're we've seen
epsilon and mu but delta seems to be the
scarier one it's highly transmissible
and still deadly but less deadly this
really makes sense so now
we're getting to that point perhaps
where you know people are saying we have
to live with covid
but
this the worst strain of kova will
probably fizzle itself out so i'll throw
back to the 1918 flu pandemic for
another point of data
there's a a one one historical theory
that the 1918 pandemic started in china
as a very uh as a lighter string
and a bunch of people got it and they
got over it but then it moved into the
trenches came back to the united states
where it festered and got worse
and because it had the ability to
rapidly in fact close quartered people
who were injured or sick
that allowed for a very serious variant
to rapidly infect lots of people
by the time it made it back to china
the people of china already had some
natural immunity to to the similar
strain and were less impacted by it
in this instance it's similar but
different
the very serious strain was struggling
because we did the slowdown we did the
lockdowns we did these things i think
it's fair to say we probably had a
positive impact in that regard but then
variance can still persist and we made a
lot of mistakes notably
being indoors seems to be bad being
outside with fresh air with uv lights
with vitamin d with exercise seems to be
good so we made some mistakes in the
capacity we need to update our strategy
now i think we're in a new pandemic a
pandemic of political manipulation where
we do have a crisis
chronovirus is really bad we're still
hearing stories about people getting it
but now you've got political parties
that are like now's our chance never let
a good crisis go to waste exactly and i
mean they're doing that and you know
part of the issue as well though you can
actually argue with the lockdowns is
that you allow and incentivize mutations
when you lock down because when they
finally get out or when they have to
actually go out and they've been locked
down for so long they're spreading a
much more mutated iteration it went
through about five or six viral viral
generations and now you're getting
something that there's always a small
chance that when a virus mutates that it
can demonstrate a little bit more
virulence and it can become a lot more
deadly but that's interesting locking
down essentially created isolated
incubation
is our viruses more or less likely to
mutate in isolation
it isola
pretty much if we never lock down what
would happen is that everybody
covet would burn through its host
reservoir eventually we would reach herd
immunity a lot faster that's at least
you know that's the traditional logic i
think it still stands there's a lot of
inconsistency on it and i'm not going to
give you a definitive but what happens
is you let it burn through its host
reservoir and again people are going to
you know people are going to succumb to
the illness that's part of the nature of
it but
once it actually burns through
everybody's already immune you know
they're immunized so you don't have
a
let's say a generation one covid and
then generation five you know a
generation five
encoded illness going and then
generation five is so much different
from generation one that eventually you
get a chance mutation that allows it to
spread a little bit easier a question if
you don't know the answer it's okay if
if uh if you become immune to like alpha
of covet alpha it can it mutate in your
system once you develop immunity to the
alpha can it
that that's always a possibility that's
actually something that you know we take
well okay
it's complicated because once you have
the antibodies once you have the
immunoglobulin g antibodies within your
blood once it's there
again it's going to eventually get wiped
it's going to eventually get wiped out
and then the rest of your antibody
production will catch on lymphocytes and
the dendritic cells will begin to
dispose of it so you will eventually get
rid of the infection entirely
but the issue is again
what it you know how do you control for
whatever you're spreading because you
have
a thousand different variants of the
virus here and once that's the most
transmissible will then be able to be
shed to somebody else
and then that one will actually spread
and it'll copy those transmits you know
it'll actually
carry those same transmissibility traits
and it might actually improve on that
further and further and further and then
they might actually spread that one but
you know it's all chance it's like
you know you're rolling the dice every
single time because first you have to
actually spread the most transmissible
variant of invariant of it and then you
have to hope that that one doesn't
self-terminate or snuff itself out every
single time that it's hijacking a cell
and getting itself to be reproduced
if it snubs itself out or if you don't
actually spread it and your body
actually develops immunity to it
you know that's that's game over so it's
basically a chance thing that's why i
say mutations are they're drummed up to
such a degree that you know it's like
tim said they're not letting a good
crisis go to waste but really this is
something mundane that we're making
sound
so exotic i think i think initially
i actually do think the initial like
everything we saw initially was accurate
and we have to we have to make sure
we're updating the science as as the
mutations happen and assess our economic
circumstances it started with a novel
virus that it was highly infectious and
it was novel so it's likely going to hit
everybody
and it was just uh uh as they reported
not a lab leak but just very
interestingly it had these proper you
know infection methods but in the
beginning they're like look nobody's had
this so that means everyone's going to
get it there's no natural immunity to
this and that means we're going to see a
lot of death and so we wanted to do
something about it i think that was
legitimate but what happens is
with mutations with bad policy we're not
perfect we make mistakes we should have
done different things i can accept that
trump should have fired fouchy i
definitely think that is fauci has got
no confidence in the american people
but it's hard to say we're at a point
now where i'm wondering if the hard
lockdowns allowed for isolated
incubation so put it this way
if the population is rapidly
intermingling then there will be
variants but people will quickly catch
certain strains and then develop
immunity to those strains granted with
the novel virus we're talking about a
lot of deaths so it's a scary sentence
you know it's scary to just be we're
going to ignore this well then you get
overloaded hospitals
but if you tell everyone to lock down
then what happens is let's let's let's
say you have 10 buildings that are
sealed
each with their in each are infected
with kovid
when they open the doors you could you
could have ten variants because they
went through multiple like you said five
or six generations now it comes out with
ten different strains all at once
so
look i'm not gonna pretend to be an
expert on this or background policy
somebody is at this point right right
it's hard to know for sure the one thing
i can say is when you look at australia
you look at what's happening with
democrats i think
they're like it's an opportunity for us
to push through agenda items to to you
know do a lot of things now
interestingly i guess you know gretchen
whitmer like his opposing vax mandates
and and mask mandates polling or polling
was bad or something like that she
missed out on numbers all right she's
for the people well i i'm glad that's
the case but i don't think it's going to
save her career i think too many
democrats saw this as an opportunity
they started by saying come on down to
chinatown that's what nancy pelosi was
saying remember that nancy pelosi not
wearing a mask getting her hair done
gavin newsom not wearing a mask going to
these restaurants they don't care about
this and i'll tell you this celebrities
aren't scared of this at all no take
into consideration that they go to the
emmys they'll go to the mat golly they
don't wear masks they don't care they
literally do not fear this at all so if
you're sitting at home and you're
worried and you're scared about this ask
yourself why it is that political elites
and celebrities have zero fear they go
on tv they don't wear masks they go to
special events they don't wear masks
they do not care about this
there's the infam there's just such an
informational lag because i think
conservatives are on the cutting edge of
this conservatives have already gotten
to the point where we've accepted that
this is going to be an endemic virus
it's not as bad as it could be practice
good health get outside again because
you need the vitamin d and also because
heat stimulates interferons which can
help again help your body actually ward
off the virus a lot of people want to do
research into interferons children also
have a much higher
number of interferons within their nose
and that's part of the reason why
children are less susceptible in general
wow but um you know there's so many
there's so many facets to this that the
average person does not know and there's
an information light because they're
getting it from these traditional
sources so what do you do
you make more interferons baby hey so
you're saying it's
endemic which means what does that mean
exactly that means that you're going to
it's basically a part of society you're
going to have a code every single year
and as yourself how long have we had a
flu vaccine
oh we've got a bunch of different ones
okay have we gotten rid of the flu yet
okay so why are we trying to do the same
thing with kobe right but i always call
it the flu shot is that because it i
thought it wasn't a vaccine well it's a
it's a more traditional one the mrna
vaccine is where you're exposing
yourself to two specific spiked proteins
out of the 26 that are on the surface of
the sarcov2 virus but these have what's
called a pre prefusion conformation
which keeps spike protein from damaging
the cell
basically as it's uh you know as it's
manufactured and it actually locks it
onto your cell in the uh plasma membrane
of the cell so it can't get losing and
go and damage other cells this is the
rna one
yeah that's rna it helps your body
basically produce the spike protein so
that you can create those igg or igg
jesus christ
antibodies that's that's the worst
naming convention i'm so glad you're
here
it's complicated it's super it's super
complicated but it's also niche too
because again a lot of urologists
they'll study this and they won't put
two and two together and then you know
you have some virologists that dedicate
themselves to studying interferons you
have some they dedicate themselves to
say studying different methods to deploy
you know
vaccine that's
pretty much how we have the
80 26 in the jansen and that's how we
have the
nanoparticle the lipid covered
nanoparticle of basically the pfizer one
and so uh what's what's a traditional
vaccine called is that a name
i would say a a live
well no it wouldn't be the live teamwork
right yeah that's pretty much it where
you're presenting an inner copy
so the uh novavax i think
that's one that's a traditional vaccine
is that a live attenuated or
oh i might actually have to go look at
that the specifics of which i'm i'm
super do you know anything about the
johnson johnson vaccine yes it's it's a
dna virus it's a dna vaccine
right i think it's still our i thought
it was still rna but it was just
deployed using a uh adenovirus that was
actually found in research monkeys i
could be wrong but i thought that it was
still that we're still dealing with rna
kind of as a more general question
do you think that there's a lot of
promise in the rna vaccines in general
i mean it's a it's a useful way to do
what we've always done but you know the
weakness of the rna vaccines is again
it's blood-borne immunity which means if
you have something that transmits or
sheds via the the nodes you're still
able to transmit because that's a
different antibody that you're trying to
produce so it works on blood but not in
mucus not in the lymph yeah those would
be the iga antibodies that you that you
find there your saliva and i believe in
your stomach
if and so it says dna it says that
johnson johnson uses an adenovirus to
deliver the spike protein dna
but
and it's nebraska medicine so i'm
assuming that i i read this too i think
i was writing on the cdc that's a dna
vaccine versus the mrna vaccine similar
but different technologies yeah it's
it's just the it's the same process just
kind of in reverse dna you're basically
cleaving it into an r you're basically
splitting it into an rna and then giving
it out to your ribosome so that they can
actually you know send it so they can
actually manufacture where it's rna
again it's already ready to go
word it's like inserting a disk into it
it's like inserting a disc with a
program into a computer so before we
move on cd-rom yeah indeed yes before we
move on i have to ask a lot of times
people will just dismiss out of hand the
concept of a vaccine altogether because
they'll tell me it's not a vaccine it's
gene therapy what do you say to that i
mean it's a semantic argument because
you know everything is you know
everything to some degree are genes like
now what i think when people say gene
therapy they're thinking kind of like a
retrovirus where it actually overwrites
the dna of your cells and causes them to
basically
by default produces like i said this is
like just inserting a cd into a computer
and telling it run a specific program
it's going to conduct i was i was
reading a harvard article about gene
therapy a lot of people were sending
saying see it proves mrna's gene therapy
it actually doesn't the harvard article
says that there is mrna gene therapy
mrna vaccines are not gene therapy so
the idea is
basically what they're saying if you've
got a genetic disorder
they can use mrna to literally do a gene
therapy and change the dna in your cells
to stop the disorder but these vaccines
don't do that right they just give the
rna to make a spike protein and then
eventually cease to exist they allow the
ribosomes to basically better work and
you know again mobilize the aminos to
conduct the protein and it's only two
out of the uh 26 that you know you
you'll find on the surface too so it's
not even like it's covering the whole
cell with it and i just think
there's a lot of other arguments people
make they use semantic arguments like
gene therapy i'm like what does that
mean like i mean does that affect the
polit the politics of freedom and
medical choice and bodily autonomy
you know fight the mandates not the
vaccines because again the vaccines are
you know vaccines are
pretty much wonderful anywhere you
actually been yes these may have you
know you might have a lot of allergic
reactions there's a lot that we don't
know how people's bodies are reacting to
it but you know people react
all medicine has risk yeah people react
oddly to all kinds of medicine medicines
and depending on what i'll put it this
way if someone comes to me and says that
they would like to get vaccinated that's
that's cool you talk to your doctor and
they'll be like yeah but that's
fantastic i'm glad you did that thank
you that's awesome i don't think we
should force people to do it though and
there's there's arguments about like
well what about all the other vaccines
and i'm like truth be told i still have
issues with government-mandated
medication i think people you know but
there's limited function right if you
want to go to a public institution like
a school and they mandate it that's
different from saying all public
accommodation period for participation
in society furthermore the older
vaccines have been around for a much
longer time and went through a
legislative process for approval
it's very different from like we're in a
crisis and we're going to just executive
decree this stuff
so i think it's like um the supreme
court said about the eviction moratorium
it's an issue for congress
laws have to be voted on in past and the
problem is when democrats realize they
can't get it through because of
republicans they just say you know we'll
squeeze it in with a budget bill we'll
do the omnibus spending where we just
get whatever we want or biden will rule
by decree yeah and that goes back to
what we said though that again the dem
the democratic party is sick and when
you have a sick party that can't get the
other wing to agree or work with it then
what you get you get these schemes these
plans these ways that you are trying to
control manipulate and snuff out the
other party and that eventually destroys
the nation because you need the ideas of
the left which left does not it doesn't
mean de facto communism let's go go to
that you know left and right are just
semantic terms that we use to describe
traditionalism which would normally be
right and then you know this whole
moving forward changing things which is
what we see left like if america was
historically a communist country the
commies would be the right yeah and you
know the left would be the capitalists
and could you imagine could you imagine
that uh a group of wall street bets uh
capitalists hurling balls off cocktails
into worker camps
yeah but they also don't like
it's not about being establishment it's
just certain political factions don't
engage in that kind of behavior yeah
whether the revolution or not but let me
show you the story we got the story from
fox news
new york governor refusing to budge on
vaccine medic for nurses you're
replaceable
i don't think they realize right we had
a story that one hospital in new york
was no longer going to deliver babies
because they had no maternity ward
nurses
it was like new york this is a bet on
this is about the new york governor is
going to lose they're not replaceable
not going to happen no who is
replaceable the governor oh yeah that's
true you know i could replace the
governor with a golden retriever we're
probably better off definitely
so when they start
firing people
i think the economy is going to just
yeah you look they they come out and
they say we're in a very serious
pandemic we need to mandate this stuff
okay what happens when you eliminate
nurses in the middle of the pandemic
pandemic gets worse
that's where we're going weren't they
just complaining that we're having a
nursing shortage i don't understand
where she's paying they're they're
literally paying travel nurses
exorbitant amount of fees to come work
for them
when they could just pay the nurses a
little bit more but no instead they're
going to go ahead and fire them yeah
what what did she say she'll bring in
foreign staff or something that's so
expensive we're sending out a call
statewide there are facilities for
example in new york that 98 of the staff
are vaccinated they don't have a worker
shortage we are working closely with
these hospitals to find out where we can
get other individuals to come in and
supplement nursing homes and other
facilities her comments come after she
had already said on tuesday while
visiting the niagara power project those
who refuse we will find replacements
those who refuse you have my utmost
respect
do not give the government an inch they
will take 10 miles it's a power play
that's that's all it is because i mean
again if you have nurses refusing the
vaccine mandate and nurses are regarded
as health professionals then what do you
think is going to happen to the rest of
the people
these these certainly must be the
stupidest nurses on the planet to be in
these hospitals where they can actually
see the vaccine workings and then reject
them
what strange individuals i'm being
facetious by the way the point is i
don't know what they're experiencing and
there are a lot of people who like the
left have been like wow these someone
actually treat us on the left they're
like these nurses must be really stupid
to be working in the hospitals where
they can see the vaccines work and
refuse them and it's like
maybe they're still breakthrough cases
maybe there's like it doesn't matter if
you're a nurse and you see people coming
in for covet you're not going to see a
grand global overview of the numbers
well it all goes back to what do you
define as a breakthrough case because
again
i think the vaccines were rated even at
their peak for like 95 90 efficacy so
what do you call the other five percent
what do you call the other 10 that's
expected so that's not even a break
again that's a semantic fear word like
breakthrough case oh your vaccine it may
or may not work no we've already
controlled for that but the fact is you
get the vaccine you have a better chance
of surviving you can develop real
immunity now the issue with the whole
nurses refusing mandate is if you get if
you get the vaccine
you get and you get the sarcov2 virus up
in your nose you can still spread it but
you don't know you have it because your
symptoms are reduced so now they can
potentially spread it to even more
patients because they're almost
confirmed to be a symptomatic or
especially if they have a working immune
system they're not going to have
symptoms so now you just and it's
happening
yep now it's going to be testing every
for that's controlling for a mistake
that they made because again we just
didn't have the data like i said
nobody's an expert on this you know what
i say we do it right now
i say
not a vaccine mandate
a swab mandate to enter all
establishments so every business has to
have someone employed at the door and
when you walk in they stick the thing in
your nose they put it down you wait 15
minutes or whatever how long does that
take it takes 15 minutes or no it takes
longer than that doesn't it yeah i think
about 30.
all right you stand outside for 30
minutes and then if you all right you
can come in now i got the finger the
finger test where they prick your blood
and they check or whatever that was
negative but they like put the thing on
your finger and they smash it and then
it like goes through your skin and then
they do the blood that was instant it
was like you literally look and go
you're good it's like instant was more
like the one where they put the thing on
my forehead and then they like put a
green light on my forehead or something
you guys get that and they're like yeah
oh it's time yeah yeah yeah trying to
see if the laser trying to see if
there's manifestations of you know if
you're febrile yeah that's what it's
doing for sure the story shows they
don't care about you
they don't care about your rights they
don't care about your freedom they don't
care about the constitution they will
replace you
so we should replace them
we don't need these fat cats these big
wigs it's our duty to replace them i
don't like term limits man term limits
term limits how do we make it how do we
make it happen fast we don't need to
make it happen fast how do we make it
happen legitimately midterms yes but
there are two distinct cultures in this
country that i don't think that solves
the problem at all i don't know what
does solve the problem because you can
have
uh tom cotton come out and say
we should consider whether or not covet
leaked in the lab and new york times
says crackpot conspiracy theorist you
know tom cotton puts out crackpot
conspiracy theory and then a year later
some guy former new york times is like
actually it may be and they go oh it may
be or hunter biden's laptop you they
come out and they're like they found an
old laptop there's no proof we're not
going to look at it
the npr said it's not even news we won't
entertain it twitter said we're going to
block the new york post from sharing it
and then a year later they're like oh
that laptop thing yeah that was true
yeah i had this thought that we used to
write constitutions and laws now we
write code so if the code does it
there's no like enforcement the code
happens so i mean
like
if you're living in a digital society
the code is going to dictate what you
can and can't do just by basis of what
the code is coded to do so that's like
the law is built into society at that
point the law is part of the function so
maybe that's the future like social
media you could you could use a word on
youtube that makes your video not appear
so there's like invisible enforcement
that someone put in play that is shaping
our culture without anyone's permission
we've lost without control the machine
is taking over and here's a crazy thing
it's not an ai
it's just a random amalgam amalgam of
different code and maybe some machine
learning but for the most part
they ban they ban words based on what
words
a word could sound like another word and
they they'll ban you for it they banned
sounds
website there's literally no oversight
and i mean that's argument against
having just code because again
code's going to happen there are going
to be errors because code is dealing
with people people can say something a
code can't sort out for sarcasm a code
can't sort out whether or not you're
quoting something unless you say begin
quote end quote or something like that
and if you you go that route and you
just eliminate you know let's say
enforcement or politicians in general
where's the appeal process you could
build it into the system like a jury
system uh with like a transparent free
software code and then if there's a if
someone feels like they were wronged by
the way the code acted they could appeal
to a jury of your peers like a thousand
random people could get an opportunity
to view the process and then then that
could self-alter the code if if you get
enough times that this thing has gone
wrong then the code rewrites itself or
the people
overseeing the code can rewrite it
sounds it sounds good but again if it
deals with people and it's dealing with
you know personal personal
interpretations and then you know that's
personal interpretations are being
cultivated by that same code and
algorithm then you know you're just at
back at square one interesting you know
we there's a lot of problems in that
because people are going to argue and
then you're going to get people saying
here's the real problem and it's going
to be it's going to break down as to who
gets to implement the code i think maybe
maybe one of the simplest solutions
would be if you know
you just took one person
and appointed them supreme chancellor
with absolute power to do anything
and then just said you know what you
take care of us yeah we don't have to
fight anymore
we'll just have them be allowed to do
anything and control all of the law
enforcement and uh just accept that
their decisions are law genius but
you know we we say that jokingly but the
fact that you know the fact i had a
disclaimer because but no we say that
jokingly but here's the problem
the left is constantly burning books
removing history removing the stories
and tales of when we did things like
that and when they went horribly wrong
so what happens when you get the next
generation that does come up with that
idea and they don't have the history to
tell them
you you might not want to do that it's a
big part of why i don't like that
they've censored the swastika because
you need to know
you got to know the history of the nazi
party man you gotta know there's there's
cartoons family guy justice league that
they show these symbols and now it's
like they're like oh we can't show that
it's offensive i'm just assuming that
they ban the swap i don't know if the
swastika is banned can you show a
swastika on youtube
uh it is it is
algorithmically reduced in a lot of
capacities and depending on the context
twitter would what might remove it or
put or flag it and there's a big
difference we talked about this before
the show talking about something racy
like a word is very different than using
that word
to describe someone or attack someone
but it should matter for of course you
know it shouldn't matter for the future
no no it matters to human beings it
doesn't matter to the machine yeah the
machine doesn't care why
you you know or actually i think it no
longer matters to the people either it's
like that netflix executive was it was
explaining to people racial slurs and
why they were banned and what they were
and he got in trouble for saying it
imagine being part of like a diversity
and inclusion thing where you're like
we're going to be explaining racial
slurs why they're offensive and why you
can't say them and then someone gasps
when you say it to tell them not to say
it and he got fired so he gets this
netflix like it's called to hr and
they're like what happened he goes i was
explaining to them racial slurs and like
what was not acceptable and and i said
and they went
he said it again it's like well you
asked him
what he got fired lost his job john
schnatter yeah look at papa john we had
papa john in the show he was explaining
on a phone call how this word's
offensive and like you know colonel
sanders used it nobody even got mad at
him and they were like oh he said it
he didn't call anybody any racial slurs
saying the sound is so different than
calling someone a name keep that i could
call you a really i could be like call
you a name that's like an innocuous word
and it's more offensive than if i'm
discussing the etymology of a word there
was a period where uh people were using
facebook skype twitter as like slurs
trying to get the word banned i guess or
whatever the point was but there was a
period where it was like the left was
writing saying like these are now slang
for racist terms or whatever and it's
like oh geez
in the in the kyle rittenhouse case
apparently the judge said he didn't
recognize the okay symbol as a symbol of
white supremacy and that he thought it
was um what would he say used it it was
really funny literally everyone let me
see the sailor man i'm curious i don't
remember
i've seen aoc threw up two of them right
now so did obama a-okay
dog whistles i know it's perfect it
means well actually it could be more of
a dog whistle seeing how the progressive
parties basically you know again who's
it a dog whistle for
and who is hearing the dog whistles is
it a dog i'm never saying it's like we
never considered the possibility that
these people could be entirely
subversive they could be virulent bigots
and this could have been like a 10-year
plan to get in
under the guise of being an ally and
eventually turned it back or turned the
country back to the age of jim crow
chef by rd oh yeah yeah yeah
that's a good point i haven't had a lot
so yeah the judge said the okay sign is
you also used uh as a game and in old
chef boyardee campaigns
i certainly would keep the door open if
you can show that there's any connection
between the defendant on the day in
question and this organization but as i
said before if this organization
embraces the defendant after the fact
and he's lionized because of his
behavior that is not something that the
jury can make anything out of that would
be lawful
wow
yeah
now the question is ian again with
algorithms do you get that level of
nuance into it
can an algorithm be that nuance and make
that judgment call at this stage i don't
think so
i would hazard that it can
it will never unless you get algorithm
that's so sufficient that it can replace
humans entirely what would what would
happen is okay you make the okay sign on
you know on your mind's video and then
it
the ai flags it and it's like hey
offensive thing and then you're like no
i wasn't doing it offensively i was
doing it
non-offensively so then you you re
appeal it and then it goes out to like a
thousand people that get to vote
is he did he use it in context or is the
ai right and then they vote and then the
ai changes itself no no no that's ideal
and once once again your idea is absurd
and wrong i'll tell you what we should
do and mine should roll this out
as you're posting there should be a
little circle with like a red light
that's you know flash a little bit and
if you're about to post something
offensive it goes i'm afraid i can't let
you do that yeah
you're like i want to be freezing your
blood yes
hold still i want to post this meme i'm
afraid i can't let you do that here cryo
freezer initially
and then robotic arms can come out of
the ceiling still hold still yeah it's
for your own goodness he's going to
amnesticize you and take away the will
that you ever had the poster oh yeah one
andreas has been talking about neural
net and one of the things they might do
with it is for prisoners violent
prisoners rather than put them in prison
put them on a neural net that like
dampens their will of power
digital lobotomy i don't know if that's
ethical but it's a use of the technology
ethics committee would never go for that
again that's uh but like is it ethical
to put someone in prison for 20 years
you know it's kind of the argument again
then it's like kind of what do you do
with it when you have an unrepentant you
know these are imperfect and we're
dealing with people people are imperfect
and these problems unfortunately will
never have a perfect neat answer all you
can do is just mitigate harm and
unfortunately you know it goes back to
the pandemic
democrats haven't figured out that
you can't do anything you just got to
mitigate the harm there's no perfect
need but
everybody's a coward well there's power
and regular people and the people in big
cities are terrified they're like they
scream that's what zubi just tweeted out
he was like i mean she's been traveling
the us and he was like man these blue
states whatever like talking about the
big cities this is so much fear and it's
really dampening my vibe it's messing
around
i want to go back to florida and texas
yeah west virginia it's like life is
normal it's weird to see uh going to the
casino they ban masks because it's a
casino and they're like you can't wear
masks but people still do it they don't
say anything but i'm like it's kind of
weird people are smoking in there west
virginia man we got freedom it really is
great
but yeah freedom if you can keep it i
guess freedom is scary though to an
infantilized people and that's the
problem is that again people in our
stage this is why i'm black people i i
know liz i'm not supposed to do that i'm
not supposed to do that but i'm
blackpilled when it comes to
you know
libertarianism in general because
libertarianism would have worked with
when people were more rugged more robust
more open to risk but now everybody's so
infantilized it's like the uh the muscle
doge meme and the little jeans and it's
like
it's kind of like you know back in the
day people were all just they would take
risks they would do what they needed to
do nowadays it's like someone called me
a mean word online now if there's
something you don't know you just look
it up that didn't exist before that's it
that's something we have and but i mean
the search for the knowledge like just
doing something more than google search
like going to your library and grabbing
a book that allowed you to uncover more
but we don't have that now you can just
look something up and people are people
are so spoiled you have to ask people
there's a funny so much conversation was
hey what is
can you answer this
there was a there's a funny comic where
it's like it says then it's like two
guys sitting down and one guy goes hey
what year was abraham lincoln
assassinated the other one goes i don't
know you want to go to the library not
really okay and the panel below it's
like now hey what year was abraham
lincoln assassinated then he holds up
his phone and what was it 1864.
before i don't know that exactly
let's go super chats everybody if you
haven't already you must smash that like
button it is your sworn duty
and subscribe to the channel go to
timcast.com become a member share the
show with your friends let's uh let's
read some of these fancy messages ooh
this one's good you know who says
malcolm flex has the deep gravely
baritone voice that could serenade me
into walking off a cliff he were to use
his powers for evil pay me five dollars
and i will say whatever you want i will
make a cameo page we can get this going
right now
lincoln was assassinated in 1865 april
14th so close i am many things but i am
not a historian nor am i good with
specifics so lua coder says tim why are
we giving billions of dollars to foreign
countries when our economy is falling
apart these politicians do not care for
americans and only value their overseas
pet projects
i completely agree that's why i think
it's a challenge when it comes to israel
because it's like oh do we let it just
be peppered with rockets and then see
all this mass death
should we be securing the face mask of
those hidden expos before securing our
own there's a good argument for not
providing funding not because it's
israel and here's the issue
if you came to me and said i think we
should reduce all of our foreign
spending until we can resuscitate
america and maybe even drop it down to
near zero or zero i'd be like we should
have a discussion when aoc is like i
don't like israel i'm like shutting off
yeah get out of here stupid argument you
don't care about the economy she's just
in this weirdo world of israel bad
rashida taleb is like there are it's
humanitarian crisis and there are war
crimes and i'm like you see if you
really cared about foreign spending
you'd be talking about all the other
countries we're dumping money money into
as well not just israel they're just
obsessed because they are lunatics they
are obsessed with this stuff you know
what really really frustrates me more
than anything are the anti uh israel
zealots and the pro-israel zealots i'm
like dude you can be pro you can be andy
if we can have a conversation but i
can't stand people like aoc who are like
screaming and they're like
you're dedicating your time and energy
to one country calm down give me some
principled opposition like this was
right here we shouldn't give billions of
dollars to foreign countries when our
economy is failing that's a really good
point little coder you're correct i
agree with you aoc i don't i think she
just hates israel yeah a lot of these
people weren't even alive when when the
conflict went on so they're just picking
aside based on some skewed iteration of
history that we've already said let's
not do white rat says nothing says
strong political figure when they when
they cry if they don't get their way
it's true
amazing
all right let's see queen slay she
thinks it'll work she lives on the
internet irish fish says
the left cult is not stupid they are
crazy also check out neon genesis
evangelion and akira
yes interesting
yeah all right oregon life says ian you
mentioned you voted for biden knowing
what you know now would you make the
same decision why or why not you're a
borderline commie i never said that
though did i no i voted for obama in
2008 so technically by default biden was
involved in that but i didn't vote for
biden i didn't vote this last election i
couldn't bring myself to do it
interesting i mean also i just moved so
it was a big challenge you want to know
something that's really bad i don't want
to cut that off but you know if biden
gets 25th
or he dies
or
you know worse you know if something
happens to joe biden we won't get a
president trump because president trump
is going to be that same age i think the
independents are going to look at it and
say
do we really want to go down there
so that's something young scientist yeah
i want like an ethical genius in office
right now well tell your gop to find
them
[Music]
so i'm i i'm probably pronouncing this
name wrong every time i do because i
don't know what it is leg i'm a thighen
but he says sounds latin ian you're my
bro but israel isn't a theocracy most
israelis are secular jews
you can be any religion or none the land
was split into two states by the u.n in
1948 israel was instantly invaded and
defeated the invasion the history is
highly complex it is very is israel not
a jewish state
lurch says the last super chat is
complete bs israel was not invaded they
waged a campaign of ethnic cleansing in
1947 and a handful of arab soldiers came
to try and stop it
see this is what happened there you go
yeah
are they talking about the six day war
is that what it was there's so there's
so many different things they did like a
blitzkrieg against uh uh egypt because
egypt and israel had had all this
conflict and there was like this
blitzkrieg and then this takeover of
land i think it was in 67 though that
was longer further away all right fidel
leblanc says had no idea until the other
night that you're a weeb love fullmetal
alchemist brotherhood what's your
favorite anime manga ps love the show
watch every night
i think i'm gonna go for the obvious and
say naruto because when naruto was in
its manga run shonen jump every week i
would pull the scandalation this was
like 10 years it's crazy when i think
back i'm like there's a period was like
oh it's wednesday and i would pull up
and i would read the latest chapter and
then i'm like and then it ended i will
say the last few chapters i thought were
terrible yeah are you familiar with the
naruto oh yeah yeah i'm very yeah i
thought the kaguya stuff went over the
top and it was too nuts and wacky and
i'm like the problem is kishimoto he can
bring himself to kill off moderate like
at some point mataro was he was hyped up
he was foreshadowed and he was just the
perfect villain
and you know again especially when you
know the five kage summit he literally
solo the whole the strongest ninja in
the verse and how do you how do you do
that when he got the sage powers i was
like this is great but then when the
kaguya stuff started and he was like a
pawn i'm like this is yeah it's the
aliens the black sets and the black
zetsu and then you know they expounded
upon it with wars though but it's just
like this is tanking and yeah you know
it was just
he did too good overwhelmingly the
series is really really really really
great full metal alchemist brotherhood i
mean both series were really really good
and uh i got to give a shout out to fuli
cooley back in the day oh i remember
watching it on adult swim right what was
it six episodes it was uh wacky show
limited run total absurdism
they tried making sequels to it they
just don't work but that is a classic
classic series and then i gotta say
these are really obvious but death note
i will give a shout out to that time i
got reincarnated as a slime i think is
pretty good i stopped watching it a
while ago and there's another show i
can't remember the name of maybe you
guys in the chat can remind me of it
it's about a dude
they're in a they're in like a training
class for like nights or something and
then he's in a dungeon but he falls
and then he's gonna die so he eats a
monster but then becomes like a hybrid
monster you saw that one yeah yeah and
then he's like going through the dungeon
leveling up getting ultra strong and his
arm gets chopped off or whatever and
then when he finally escapes he's super
powerful and like a demon of some sort i
don't know i can't remember the name of
that show i watched that one that was
really cool yeah it's odd it sounds like
set up for that almost sounds uh eerily
similar to the setup for jiu-jitsu
kaizen like
from the eating of the finger and you
know almost becoming a monster
that again just kind of drawn parallels
hair my hero academia is pretty good it
is it's yeah but these are all like the
really obvious cliche ones yeah did you
guys are getting a sword art online
sword art online
it doesn't get good until the gun gale
part and even after that because i mean
kirito's he's a gary stew you know it's
like he's perfect in every in every way
in the series and even in the real world
it's just
like he's a kendo practitioner so he's
got reaction skills and it's like
you know at some point
it just it lost luster i thought boy
bebop man greatness
it's such a bummer that it only got 26
episodes they had i guess it was too
violent at the time and they didn't want
to renew it but that show the lore
they're gonna they're they're saying
they're gonna expand the canon with
netflix with the netflix live action
yeah i don't trust it either especially
because edward's not in the trailer
so i'm like yo
i don't trust it what's what did you say
the john show the john cena maybe yeah
it's not a movie tv show
all right serge says democrats are
trying to pass legislation to prevent
people who self-direct ira accounts from
investing in anything but the stock
market no more crypto or real estate
investments this is scary
wow
jeez christopher reilly says please read
this have modern renaissance man on your
show he would be a really he would be
really fun to watch on your show well
okay
we'll take a look
all right let's see we got
drew richmond says we need a tim pool
the science fool shirt bill nye was the
inspiration here of course a better
rhyme would be needed fool is not
complimentary the science
temple makes science cool there you go
that works yeah
you do now tim shoddy viceroy says i
work in the solar industry in the
process for pv arrays is very
interesting photovoltaic especially the
dc to dc link battery systems are super
cool also the inverters switch
igbts for for dc to ac after being
broken up through a sein filter oh i
have no idea what that means sounds cool
huh science a lot of people do i learned
that from watching rogan's podcast he'd
have these geniuses on and they'd be
talking to him he'd just sit there and
listen and not understand anything they
said he's like but it's getting recorded
i can either watch it later or there's a
bunch of people that know what he's
talking about it's it's a good gateway
podcast yes yeah definitely peter
provenzano says tim the us is buying the
iron dome to defend the air bases in
guam japan south korea we basically paid
for the r d for the defensive weapon in
south korea it's called thaad
yeah i forgot what it stands for
aerial defense maybe something like that
and there are protests against it
they're worried that it'll it'll uh
increase the tensions between north the
north and the south yeah when i was
there they were like signs saying like
no thaad in south korea
interesting
all right let's see what we got here
justin bell says as fall comes in i will
be able to see three mile island from my
front porch
that sounds cool
nice
derek jones says ian i have i have an ms
and wrote a thesis on horizontal gene
transfer hgt is the non-sexual transfer
of genetic material eg dna rna between
organisms you've been conflating it with
other phenomena i'll tweet dm you good
sources i'm a fan of what you all do
thanks very cool amazing
he's a messenger oh yeah have you
studied the gene translations much
lateral and horizontal gene translations
not near as much i haven't delved into
that one when you start getting into the
pairings and translating transcripting
and all that that's where you
literally
complicated bn says even nuclear isn't
as uncommon as you're making it sound in
the u.s we have 56 nuclear power plants
operating across 28 states and maybe we
should have
112 operating off of
56 states maybe we can have three
million ones in our pockets encased in
carbon glass
little tiny ones well i was reading we
had you saw the solid state battery
thing like several months ago or last
year or whatever
i don't know they had a breakthrough in
solid state batteries which are
extremely energy dense
so it's like your phone could last 10
days off one charge or something like
that but it isn't crazy otherwise it
isn't the downside of anything solid
state is that it dies almost like
instantaneously and at random like you
know when when assault stills estate
sales go out like they're done
and i don't know the only thing about it
that was kind of like to push a push
against uh going from just hard disk
drives to solid state because again
solid state drives you know
there's a finite amount of charges that
can pass through and they just
eventually become non-functional whereas
hardness you can manually extract the
data from it
captain says tim you keep praising
thomas massey because he has spicy
tweets but he won't help pass anything
in congress he voted against the trump
wall three times with every dem he voted
against trump at every turn including
usmca he also vote voted against lauren
bobert's pro-2a leg
good criticism i will accept that and i
will look more into it but that's a good
point mostly it's like i see thomas
messi standing up and saying a lot of
things okay
we'll take we'll take a deeper look
that's a fair point should have been
doing in the first place you know we
need we need more pets in congress i
want to see them bringing in their dogs
and their cats
humanize that yeah it's all positive
until the progressive's sick and sick of
doberman on somebody across the aisle
then
that'll be exciting if nothing else oh
yeah certain i think tom matt tom
smashing this farm that's what made me
think oh yeah yeah you can read some
goats and be awesome
dave vd says just here to shout out my
amazing girlfriend hannah wallace and
her album she released on spotify called
learn to love me it'll leave you
speechless
amazing nice job hannah that's right
good work
alex r says the difference between
soviet and american reactors is how to
slow down neutrons soviets use graphite
we use water slowing neutrons increases
the chance for fission chernobyl
occurred because graphite won't boil
like water and it sprayed graphite
radioactive all in the air and yeah that
was really bad
exciting
cj says as a former reactor operator i
love the enthusiasm but this discussion
is making my eyes bleed love the show
when the radioactive floorbow particle
meets the zombo
and then they collide splitting into 17
quarks the quark starts spinning
creating a time dilation
just say
leptons and fermions yes start jumping
and then when they jump it generates
isoelectricity
let's just say words spinners spinners
happen full speed
about all that and i don't know the
details but jack keeps on telling me
about it like cern
apparently you know something makes
happen with cern so that might be
interesting in 2012 it did i'm big into
excitons that's a cool part
and you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to lecture me on this yeah for sure
that's how you make antimatter
corn 5656 says hey tim been watching
since the beginning of tomcat's irl and
y'all have inspired me to get in shape
it allowed me to evaluate my life
choices and kick myself in gear ian is
the best guru skulls for the skull
throne
um i tell you this man
if you're not in shape
and then you get in shape
it it's the feeling is so amazing you
don't know what you're missing out on
like always feeling good
i gotta say flex i've been looking at
your ripped arms what's your
what's your uh how about that
yeah
what's your workout regime like oh god
look let's just say
i'm probably one of the lucky few that
won genetic lottery of not having very
many myostatins so i don't lose muscle
and i gained a lot of this during a long
robust football career
and but honestly i would say for anybody
that wants to you know at least build
respectable arms
high volume
volume really is king and if you don't
go too high low reps yeah uh i i
actually go higher on the reps only
because again you don't you don't want
to go too high in weight you don't want
to tear something when you say high
volume what do you mean exactly like
lots of lots of uh rep sets sometimes
you know rest pause sets making sure
it's the final number needs to be as big
as possible not so much you know having
super dense rep sets just make sure that
you get to a certain high amount okay
freedom thought says watched your
segment on dating story you read sounds
a lot like my situation very few matches
and when i do they rarely message back
i've had a handful of no-shows rural
living so the only place is the bar
don't want that
so there's a there's a this viral post
from the other day
where this woman she's 33 she said i was
trying to help my brother who's 31 date
he was having problem with online dating
and i said you must be doing something
wrong so i'll take your profile i'll put
your pictures up i'll set it up and then
i'll send out some messages to get
things started for you and show you how
to talk to women because clearly you
must be doing something wrong then she
said i'm totally depressed now there's
no there's no matches there's no
responses women won't talk to me at all
i don't understand what i'm doing wrong
or why it's happening how can men deal
with this this is a nightmare for women
you get you get a response every time
you send a message out you get unlimited
you get massive amounts of matches you
get you can go through all the matches
and i'm like wow you know
i think men don't understand how women
have it women understand how men have it
but i do think men understand a little
bit better how women have it than women
understand how men have it
um
yeah that's just my perspective maybe
i'm wrong but i do think it's
fascinating when you get these feminists
saying like men have it so so much
better than women and i'm like man
five times the homelessness and five
times five times the suicide death you
know 98 of combat death
look everybody's got good things and bad
things but i think perspective is
important
and i think the issue is one of the ways
i've explained it is
men have no value at as when they're
young they have no status no strength
they're not they're not they're not
adults they don't have muscle mass so
there's like very little they can do in
terms of lifting stuff for construction
or planning things
so they're just considered less valuable
women are prime value this is according
to evolutionary biology and because of
they can have kids and i'm not saying
it's a good thing i think you know we as
a society have evolved beyond just being
like we're baser you know just
reproducing animals but what happens
then is we still have these tendencies
from from evolutionary biology that we
over protect women because they have
higher value than men and then we
undervalue men because they can't do
much for society based on again
evolutionary biology so things start to
invert around 30 when men all of a
sudden have wealth and status and career
and women you know are no longer in
their prime years for having kids
these are things that i think are bad we
should consider if you want to take the
feminist approach and be like women
should be treated this way you got it
men should be treated this way either so
that means we need to make sure that
younger men are getting a better shot at
things and being treated well and women
as they get older are being treated well
everybody has equal opportunity however
there are natural tendencies because of
human biology and that what happens in
dating
i think i think the data from okay cupid
was that
something like the top 10 percent of men
are getting 80 of the women yeah women
don't respond to average men they have
no interest in doing so and it makes
sense if every guy messages every every
woman they can no one can scroll through
and look for the best looking guy and be
like him and ignore everybody else
men don't have that option and they've
got to pick up litter again men have to
be the hunters the gatherers the forgers
and it's a zero-sum game you know if you
don't have a woman then it's not like
you're you know a new woman is created
for you if you get a woman then that
means that's one woman that another guy
is not going to get date so it's you
know the competition is much higher i
kind of kind of treat it like a video
game man online dating is crazy
yeah it doesn't work not right like i
have no luck online dating but when i
meet women i have insane i mean it's
just it's easy to stick to that
it's the vibe you know you can't get
that in a picture it's not the video
it's that
when you go out to an event to bar
market wherever where you naturally meet
people
people are walking around and it's
fairly um fifty-one percent men for you
know i mean 40 50 women 40 men and let's
say you're at like an amusement park or
you're at a music venue
and then you see a woman and you start
having a conversation yeah it's because
you're like the guy there you go up and
say hey how you doing and then she's
like cool and you you you vibe online
dating literally every single guy is
screaming at the top of their lungs
i want a girlfriend all at the same time
and women are just like uh you let's get
out of here so you have no chance to
even say hello
right so
online that's why they did bumble women
message first
and so i think that's a smarter move
because then
men don't spam message women and the the
issue then still is though the okay cuba
data that you know ugly ugly and average
women still try and message attractive
guys they go high and they go high and
unfortunately we go low i hate to say
that but
all right grayson resident says tim as
an investor please check your fax tesla
earned 788 million dollars last quarter
regulatory credits excluded good point
well take that uh into consideration
everyone else and then google it because
i was just saying something i read in an
article and not uh uh not well-versed on
the tesla stuff
dutch uh dutch our gen says physicists
here most ng turbines burn gas directly
in the turbine like a jet engine wow no
water needed there you go helium nuke is
2p2m hydrogen is just p d versus h
fusion
is easier as it needs to make less n
co2 is what plants eat the world is
getting greener
well there you go
and that's kind of what i said again you
know carbon and carbon dioxide is really
a problem because we have a system human
human body exchange carbon dioxide
plants feed off of it you know they
produce oxygen we you know it's a cycle
nature heals itself here's here's a good
and uh a good interesting and new
question rudy c winslow says ian what
are you what's your opinion on rights do
you believe they are granted to us by
god
i'm just kidding don't answer him
that's a joke our family video says i
love you guys but technology isn't
really within your scope looks at ian
please try to get isaac arthur sfia
you could have amazing discussions on
science and futurism a truly epic
crossover yeah and i'm gonna agree with
you i'm kind of a guy that knows a
little bit about a lot of different
stuff and i want to highlight the really
important things in society so sometimes
i get a little excited and talk about it
a little bit more than i'm
you know comfortable with i can't vouch
for it i'm the same way again it's kind
of a jack-of-all-trades and kind of deal
unfortunately something just goes
lacking sometimes or sometimes you're
not as well-versed because you're
spreading finite time on a bunch of
different topics i try to get
know enough about it that if i if i sit
down with an expert i i know what
they're talking about you can hold your
own at the very least
dj medero says tim sarpatch lives in ian
a once in a super chat that asks you to
read arthur c clarke's 3001 specifically
the sources and acknowledgments chapter
7 debriefing it talks about vacuum
energy and what it means it also ties
into to stargate
interesting vacuum energy zero point
energy
the source child proton
is that it's nasam harriman's paper
about quantum fluctuation vacuum
fluctuation and every proton in the
universe is two protons revolving around
each other at the speed of light
and every proton everything he's
calculated like done away with a strong
force and if you if you wanna i think
he's basically solved einstein's field
equation of like a unifying field theory
it's called the schwarzschild proton
vacuum energy we're going to get our
energy from the vacuum
yep
like the villain in um the incredibles
neo ritter says you need to watch legend
of the galactic heroes anime about two
protagonists in diametrically opposed
government systems one a dictatorship
the other democracy watch the og ova
first
you see have you read death note or
you've seen it i got into it at some
point but i think uh when l and uh
when spoiler alert oh
no it's fine we can spoil it is it 20 is
it what
20 year old show
what are the rules on spoilers i don't
know but when ellen light met that was
kind of where i i just got
it was like holy oh dude it's such a
good show if you're not familiar you
know death note right i've seen a few
episodes yeah
you get a notebook and then you write
someone's name in it and they'll die as
you say it as long as within the realm
of possibility
so this dude basically says he'll start
watching the tv and then writing down
the names of all these criminals and if
he doesn't give a reason they have a
heart attack because he wants the world
to know that criminals are dying of a
heart attack it's not it's not a
coincidence and then l is just the fake
world detective trying to track him down
but i bring it up because there is a new
one shot with donald trump in it
there is a donald trump there's a death
note comic
after the series
where
some kid gets a hold of it and then uses
the dark web or something to auction off
the death note now that everyone knows
what it is donald trump offers like an
obscene amount of money for it like 50
trillion or something because he doesn't
want other countries to get it literally
donald trump is in it and then what he
does
i'm not going to spoil it actually it is
relatively new and you should read it
because it's hilarious and it's like
it's a good comic and trump's in it
there you go and you can see how it
plays out it's interesting what more
could you want
yeah donald trump anime all that good
stuff
got it we needed it we needed that trump
anime that never came poofy says malcolm
is literally swole doge meme
yes
correct let me get a pan over here there
you go there you go you got it
this ain't even my qb second weight this
is me in a
streamline form did you play all over
the line back linebackers are you
playing the line linebackers and tight
end although again tight ends i actually
got phased out at some point because we
wanted the new sleek fast models that
run all the routes and catch did you
play left right and center linebacker
you just move around um pretty much is
inside linebacker but also when i
started out with the outside linebacker
so
designated pass rusher basically
all right
harvey slayer says we need journalists
like you to create online profiles on
every state federal politician and
record their political stances votes
scandals and overall performance the
people need to be better informed so
they can keep uh something to hold them
accountable
is there a website that can show you all
their votes i'm pretty sure there is it
could be it should be a blockchain well
i think the issue is that it does exist
i think you can go to like congress.gov
and stuff and or or bill tracker but
they're not easy
i want to be able to see like
like a picture of all of everyone in
congress and you can like click them and
then it says latest votes and it's
really easy to see
latest bills proposals latest votes
latest news articles
and then when they get uh when they get
voted out
we put them into like you know hall of
fame not a hall of fame just like
historical record you can go back and
look at different politicians and what
they voted on and it stores it
i think we just need an easy streamlined
uh system that doesn't look like a smart
contract blockchain i know it hasn't and
we would embed c-span so that like even
when you go there you can see active
voting and then we would have staff who
watch it and then enter it in real time
i sure wouldn't be cool joe biden's old
voting records unsealed that was yes
are they actually some of them yes yeah
some of the nice colorful stuff
i'd love that did he seal them or were
they always sealed who that's actually a
question i'm not annoying yeah i'm 10
sure political defiant got me
he says name of the anime you spoke of
it's arafuretta
from commonplace to world strongest araf
i'm pronouncing it probably terribly
also if we go if also if we do go
towards nuclear how do we deal with
waste in fact what should we do with all
the waste future rama futurama it to the
sun
tim ian lids and malcolm have a great
one
yes launch it into the sun i guess the
nuclear batteries that's what i've been
thinking about lately yeah nuclear waste
will be great i mean that nuclear
battery idea is like you know that's
mind-blowing it kind of does away with
centralized power grids that will all
have our own battery but it's suitable
but that's the problem though it
decentralized it where are we trending
towards
everything people you know the powers of
b will never allow that to happen
and you need funding to make it happen
m sheba says obama was in the manga air
gear as john omaha
but i'm pretty sure in the death note
one-off it's literally donald trump
called donald trump in the presidential
office saying i want to buy the death
note
you know i'll just tell you this he
doesn't get it wait don't spoil it
oh no i think he does i think he does
get it
i don't remember actually all i know is
it would be amazing if they actually did
a one-shot warts trump with the death
note
oh man that would be a great skit where
trump's sitting there like by himself in
the oval office and he's like joe biden
is so awful i'm gonna write his name
hillary clinton should be in prison
that's her that's gotta happen and then
he can manifest things other than
he gets the death note and like
lightning strikes and he cleaves into
two realities one where he becomes evil
with the death note and one where he
becomes just dude
speaking of the two realities man i i'm
still mad that you know somewhere off in
prime timeline earth president alex
jones is sending the secretary of
defense michael malus to negotiate a
treaty with china and we're missing that
that's prime earth that's probably
primer i'm sorry we're clowniverse 443
so yeah we are the clownieverse
i don't know i think we were in earth
prime
and then the large hadron collider you
know turned on in 2016
and caused you know earth prime to shake
and jostle between you know some
alternate realities and i'll tell you
this it wasn't that there was a clean
jump to another reality it was like all
of a sudden a bunch of realities slammed
together
and random particles mixed so all of a
sudden it's like you have a little bit
of random everything republicans become
democrats democrats become rebel
republicans trump gets elected duck duck
2012 cern and the first thing that came
up was sorry but we accidentally ended
the world in 2012.
there you go oh that's crazy
i'm sorry but think about this
in scientists what in the world what if
everybody's actually living in pocket
dimensions and democrats are actually
living in a dimension where covid really
is as bad as they think and we're in
like the real and we're like in a
different dimension where cove it's
actually not that bad you know we're all
free and then
like what if there's like this whole the
hollow fracta graphic universe that's
another nasa impairment theory this is a
genius we should do a spoof of what if
have you guys seen what if on disney oh
yeah i saw it the watchers watching all
these different universes we should we
should make a spoof version of like
what if but real life
in this universe donald trump never won
the election infant do you have infinite
material there too oh my god
like that actually would be really funny
i can do a real-life political like what
if what if joe biden didn't win and like
tulsi gabbard became president
re-enacted put put up a fan poll each
week and you know what episode would you
like to see and then like give them
options they choose which one and we'll
do uh what if ian crossland started tim
cast and then hired tim poole oh yeah
wow that would happen
but it would be funny because you would
literally be just wearing the same thing
as me yeah
all right everybody if you haven't
already give us a like subscribe to the
channel and go to timcast.com because
that member segment's coming up
maybe around 11 p.m or so but uh thanks
for hanging out share the show with your
friends if you like it you can follow me
at timcast basically everywhere you can
follow the show for cool clips at tim
cast irl malcolm you want to shout out
anything oh yeah certainly um
first of all obviously uh go follow me
i'm return of the flex on twitter
and also while you're at it visit
flexorsuccess.com and that's where you
can find me on other social media if you
i do all kinds of different coaching
advisement you know we can you can fill
out a form if you want to get into
e-commerce and talk about that kind of
stuff and also we're starting a
decentralized network on telegram of
content proliferation started by l
and she goes by a name that's a little
bit unclean so i can't really say it on
here but great great person we've got so
many personalities that are too spicy
for the world i think we're up to like
30 something and we're growing and we're
just spreading means information dank
content you can
send it wherever you want and get your
information unfiltered so it's like the
coolest twitter timeline that you've
ever been a part of
not on twitter that's awesome because
we're building out the fetaverse right
now and that's something that could
integrate into that system i would love
it excellent oh my gosh all right um hey
guys love you thank you for coming thank
you for keeping me honest in the
comments every day
looking forward to seeing you again
tomorrow have a great day thanks ian and
you guys all know that you are in fact
contractually obligated to click the
like button when you watch our stream
right all of you we have ten thousand
but we had like 33 i'm just kidding it's
fine so hit a like if you like it
because it does help in the algorithm
and if you would share it we would
appreciate that as well because you know
they're all out to get us anyway you
guys are welcome to follow me at sarah
patch lids on twitter although i have
achieved my goal of surpassing sour
patch kids in numbers and i can die
happy now thanks guys don't race on your
laurels i know i know we will see all of
you over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you